Untertitelung des ZDF für funk, 2017
für router gemacht zumindest am ende kam dann eine glaube 850 zeilen lange config nur für ip
ranges raus ohne config ja und ob es funktioniert weiß ich bis heute nicht naja so also wie gesagt
es ist sicher nicht nur der dhcp kaputt gewesen war ziemlich viel kaputt so wer hat noch wer hat
dann noch gesagt die erkenntnis drei monate dankeschön der general slain ist auch fünf
monaten am start wo habe ich denn wie habe ich mein fenster ein bisschen falsch hier gezogen so
als kann ich noch mal die chat angucken weil ich habe jetzt ja nicht viel gesagt zu dem was
im chat geschrieben wurde der wettbewerb ist es auch am start wollen so haben wir sonst noch der
u-bahn schreibt irgendwie scrollt man chat immer was ist das warum scrollt mein chat runter also
morgen mal
ich habe auf pfeiffer was gefunden was mich von den beiden geschlagen hat schreibt er hat dort
gibt es leute die richten komplette exchange server für 150 euro ein im freien markt zahlt
man das zwar naja das ist ungefähr genauso ernst zu nehmen wie die ganzen programmier in der die
für die eine komplette internet anwendung angeblich für 55 machen ich hab's ja ausprobiert hat ja auch
nicht funktioniert der einzige der was gemacht hat wollte mehr geld und ich hab's ja dann mal
viel mehr war es ja im endeffekt nicht und das was rausgekommen ist ja nicht funktioniert also
ja kiko du kannst den street nicht man kann seinen substream glücklicherweise nicht mehr richtig kaputt
machen auf twitch weil man immer plus 1 kriegt auch wenn man monat aussetzt das war ja früher
nicht so also sprich hast du früher 13 monat im stück abonniert und mal einmal vergessen was wir
noch bei einem monat so kann der linux dhcp server mac filter von haus aus weißt du eine mac filter
ich meine das sind reservierungen klar also dass du sagst diese diese mac bekommt diese ip klar das
ist ja so eines der basics sachen schlechthin von dem dhcp server ein linux dhcp server wäre eine
stream idee ich weiß nicht das ist eigentlich ehrlich gesagt ziemlich simpel sondern basic
dhcp server unter links in fünf zeilen config im chat gibt es hier gerade noch message war
am überlegen mir eine eigene komponente firma assistant für meine lampen in meiner wohnung zu
das ist glaube ich gar nicht so kompliziert habe ich nicht gemacht ich habe bisher nur
fertige sachen verwendet ein bisschen dran herum editiert ich glaube das geht tatsächlich ganz
gut die erkenntnis schreibt hatte letztens praktikum als fachinformatiker systemintegration
musste in einem proxmox netzwerk einen windows dhcp ich finde es interessant dass proxmox wohl
wirklich im business umfeld verwendet wird ich dachte da gibt es eigentlich so gut wie nur esx
und paar ganz verrückt da haben vielleicht noch hier links wie heißt sie heißt die wie heißt xen die
die business xen variante übelst bekannt ich komme nicht drauf ist der tricks tricks die circles
geht es vielleicht noch sicherlich dass der proxmox großartig eingesetzt werden zu sparen
keiner rechnet vorher aus was er kostet er schreibt er macht er ein tour nem schreibt ich mache im moment praxis
und muss alter warum geht mein chat immer runter das ist ja übelst nervig dass ich mir bei 90
prozent der sachen denke ah yes das ist übrigens der beste gedanke den man da haben kann denke
frage ich mich ob sich da tatsächlich jemand die arbeit macht und das zeug durchrechnen das machen
die ab und zu mal aber es ist nicht so dass da eigentlich einer der also zumindest kann ich
sagen dass da irgendwie einen großen durchblick hat den fällt jetzt ja auch teilweise nach einem
halben jahr auf scheiße das kostet irgendwie das dreifache aber ja doch doch 800 zeilen config
oder 800 850 zeilen config alles dhcp kommt jetzt nicht vor lies ist die vergeben wurden die muss
man die muss ja nicht fahren konfigurieren es ist halt teuer wie sau okay ich weiß nur dass es zum
rumspielen esx gibt ich bin nicht der große vor allem war pro ein stellenwert denkt dass die cloud
billig und einfach ist ja das stimmt
also viele sachen sind tatsächlich relativ easy wir mal ein bisschen sich darauf einlässt ja und
auch vielleicht mal man muss erst mal damit klar kommen dass man manche sachen halt nicht mehr
bestimmen kann oder hat nicht nicht nicht mehr großartig einfluss drauf hat ja aber auf der
anderen seite kann man halt sagen ja das ist auch der vorteil damit ist es ja meistens auch der vorteil von so cloud geschichten ist dass sie um so was keine Acquirements mehr machen können
deutschsee leeren usw
das ist ja hohe logan dass auch der vorteil von so cloud geschichten ist dass sie um so was keine Acquirements mehr machen können
das ist ja auch der vorteil
das ist ja auch der vorteil von so cloud geschichten ist dass sie um so was keine Acquirements mehr machen können
sich umso mehr Epicigned die individuals dürfen sich habe ich meine 반 Irlen vollständig nicht yen traction auf
dass du dir um sowas keine Gedanken mehr machen musst.
Also sprich, was weiß ich, an welchem Netzwerkport
dein Loadbalancer hängt oder sowas. Kann dir in der Cloud
vollkommen egal sein. Du kannst, wenn du Glück hast,
kannst du sagen, was du für einen Loadbalancer haben willst.
Bei Azure kannst du, also außer du installierst
das mit der VM selbst,
hast du da keinen großartigen Einfluss drauf.
Es ist ja auch
letztendlich egal,
ob du da irgendwie eine HA-Proxy hast
oder irgendeine Appliance-Geschichte
oder irgendein
Nginx-Gewurste oder so. Ist doch vollkommen egal.
Du willst einfach sagen, okay,
Loadbalancer, fertig.
So, ähm, Hyper-V.
Ne, Hyper-V habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Hyper-V ist, also generell
Windows-Windows-Welt ist nicht meins.
Also ich mache groß,
ich mache, soweit es geht,
einen großen Bogen um
jegliche Windows-Geschichte.
Ich will damit auch gar nichts zu tun haben.
Also die meisten Windows-Sachen, wir haben es ja hier im Stream
mal irgendeine Windows-Server-Version
ausprobiert. Ich kriege da wirklich...
Also es ist ja nicht so, dass unter Linux
alles schön ist. Das hat auch seine Probleme.
Ja? Also zum Beispiel, dass
gerade wenn man sich mal so
das Aushängeschild so anguckt, wo jeder
unter Linux sich mit auseinandersetzen muss, wenn du einen Server hast,
so ein bisschen Kommandozeilen-Geschichten.
Gerade da ist halt auch
total wir. Ja? Also sprich,
das eine Kommando braucht
minus V für Version, beim anderen ist es
Debug minus V
macht irgendwelche Debug-Ausgaben,
wenn man minus V macht. Dann ist es minus minus Version,
groß minus V,
alles, ja, alle Varianten. Also sonderlich einheitlich
ist das ja auch nicht.
Diese Unternehmung ist auch nicht alles toll.
Aber ich ziehe das meilenweit
einem Windows-Server vor, wo
ich
über drei Untermenü-Squeez
aus drei unterschiedlichen Generationen
irgendwelche kryptischen, auf Deutsch übersetzten
Einstellungen machen muss.
Okay, man kann es
deutsche Übersetzung ausmachen, aber trotzdem.
Ich denke, wenn man da durchblickt,
ist es auch nicht mehr ganz so schlimm.
Aber vieles ist unter Windows einfach wir.
Übertreibt man nicht hier.
Es ist die Wii-Shop-Musik.
Die Wii-Shop-Musik war die beste.
Das hat irgendwie einen dazu angeregt,
Sachen zu kaufen. Wobei ich nie gekauft
habe im Wii-Shop.
Sondern ich hatte ja
die Wii später
Custom-Firma. Der übrigens nur, also nicht Custom-Firma,
Custom, Custom, ja doch, so eine
Custom, wie nannt man das bei der Firma?
Wie nannt man diesen
Rehack damals eigentlich?
Es war ja nicht wirklich eine Custom-Firma,
es war irgendwie so ein,
so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein,
Custom Code gedönszt, keine Ahnung, wie man es genannt hat.
Zumindest war das
der Wii
sehr praktische Sache, da konntest du nämlich
Spiele von einer Festplatte laden und solche Sachen.
Es ging aber nur am ersten USB-Port lustiger Weise.
Kennst du den Cam motif, ja, kenn ich.
Hab ich aber persönlich...
...also wir haben welche.
Aber ich hab da noch nie was dran gemacht.
So sieht es aus.
Also ich, deswegen,
warum ich euch das jetzt erzählt habe.
Es kann sein,
sich weg muss dann irgendwann gleich also je nachdem also es heute ist
wahrscheinlich nichts aber man weiß ja nicht mal kurz gucken ein bisschen
verplant war das ganze ja auch mein wir haben angefangen quasi dann was zu
machen als es den ausfall gab und da ist ihnen aufgefallen um ist unser teams
geht gar nicht da haben jetzt irgendwie so eine telegramm gruppe auf
also immer ganz ganz ganz deswegen es kann sein dass je nachdem was ist dass
ich da heute noch mal hin muss aber wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich ist nix
müssen wir mal gucken ach guck mal der keeper xy jetzt auch
am start ja wahrscheinlich haben wir das irgendwann auch mal ja das fangen wir
mal an ich könnte ein bisschen über die
hardware andere leute lässt dann das mache ich ja immer besonders gerne
im stream wir können uns aber auch mal wieder eine runde das ist das gucken wir
uns jetzt an das ist übelst geil also der der typ hat es wirklich massiv
übertrieben der typ hat wirklich massiv übertrieben
der hat mit fakt ich weiß nicht ob ihr mal factorio gespielt habt der hat mit
factorio fließbändern man erkennt vielleicht hier wenn man ran zoomt der
hat mit factorio fließbändern eine der so fake 3d engine gebaut
factorio
factorio nicht kennt das ist so einen plan aufbau resource management spiel wo
man halt viele fließbänder baut hier sieht dann so aus so sieht so sieht so
sieht normalerweise es in faktor aus so und du kannst natürlich unterschiedliche
materialien produzieren und der hat einfach fließbänder gebaut man sieht's ja
hier oder nicht von unten nach oben gehen die
fließbänder und der legt halt materialien mit unterschiedlichen farben
so auf das fließband das ist halt ein bild zusammen ergibt
gibt. Das ist Massify IQ.
Heißt das dann
Factorio? Ja, aber das ist schon lang.
Das ist schon lang raus.
So, okay.
This is Factorio.
Factorio. Ich dachte, ich...
Ach, so heißt das wirklich?
Factorio? Ne, das heißt Factorio, oder?
Ich meine,
wenn das in Node.js
programmiert wäre, dann wäre das Factorio.
Aber ich dachte immer, es heißt Factorio.
Das ist übeles Big Brain. Guckt euch das mal an.
Und ihr seht es ja hier, das läuft
alles, das läuft alles, also die Fließbänder
gehen von oben nach unten, also von unten nach oben.
Das läuft alles über Fließbänder.
Er legt hier unterschiedliche Materialien
per Fließband drauf
und dann entstehen die Bilder da drauf.
Das ist Massive Big Brain.
The most notable difference
in this version is the screen.
It has a resolution.
Auf was die Leute für Ideen kommen.
Of 144 by 256 pixels.
Das ist exzellent.
This is more than 4 times as many pixels
as a screen from version 1.
The screen also supports more colors.
Das ist kein Spiel, was er da gemacht hat.
Also du kannst dich da ein bisschen bewegen.
Das ist eher so was Richtung Windows
95 Labyrinth Bildschirmschoner.
48 of them.
Let's see them all.
Ich meine, es ist schon relativ cool,
wenn man das ein bisschen kleiner macht,
dann sieht man auch nicht mehr hier die einzelnen Elemente
auf dem Fließband.
It's not just a bigger version of the old screen.
It's an entirely new type of display.
A belt-based display.
Each pixel is an item on a belt.
The image only looks to update instantly
because the footage is accelerated.
Das ist schon Big Brain, oder?
If you no longer accelerate the footage,
it looks like this.
Ja gut, das Video ist ein bisschen vorgespult,
damit man nicht sieht,
wie die Fließbänder den Kram hier rein schieben.
Of course, the items don't just appear on the belt.
They must get on there somehow.
For every second...
Da wird es dir ja schlecht bei.
...more than 2.2 million items have to be placed.
That happens here,
in this array of 2,304 inserters.
Ah, yes.
So every pixel ends up at the correct spot.
The inserters get their items from chests
filled by an army of logistic bots.
Ja, easy, easy.
Also,
also,
das ist eigentlich ganz einfach durchschaubar.
...the worker robot speeds to level 100,000
to make sure the bots can keep up.
Of course, the screen isn't the only thing that got an update.
Easy, Clem!
Every single component has been replaced
with an improved version.
It's been rebuilt from the ground up.
Note, for example, the smooth curve in the walls.
Such precision wasn't possible in version 1.
Excellent!
One of the biggest changes of the engine
is that it now scales textures.
In the previous version,
the textures were scaled in advance
and the engine just picked the correct one.
This change makes it a lot simpler to do things like
tiling simple textures into more complex ones,
like this wall.
But it also allows us to change the perspective.
So it can jump.
Or go up.
Kann sich sogar bewegen.
Another big difference is the size.
This is a screenshot of version 1,
and this is a screenshot of version 2.
With the same zoom level.
Kleiner.
Version 2 uses almost 98% less Combinators.
Let's take a look around.
Even though it already uses so few Combinators,
it's actually possible to reduce that even further.
There are a few components in here that are larger than they need to be,
mostly to make it easier to debug.
If you want something more in-depth than this little tour,
I'm considering making a few videos that explain the technical differences compared to version 1.
If you want that, subscribe to my second channel.
If you want to see version 2.1, subscribe to this channel.
It should take a lot less time than version 2.0.
And each version should bring us a little bit closer to Doom in Factorio.
Richtiger Hackerman.
Doom in Factorio.
Oh Scheiße, das könnte wahrscheinlich wirken.
Ich glaube, das kommt noch.
Doom in Factorio.
Ich meine, Doom läuft auf meinem Drucker.
Nicht der 3D-Drucker, der alte Drucker.
Der alte WLAN-Drucker.
Der hat so ein Mini-Display.
Da kann man Doom drauf installieren.
Das ist wirklich Big Brain.
Also der wird es wahrscheinlich auch schaffen, dass Doom auf meinem Klo läuft.
Geil.
Nein, übel.
Das musst du erstmal hinkriegen.
Ich läster mal ein bisschen über Technik-Setup von anderen Leuten.
Das mache ich immer gern.
Lass die Map mal im Stream anschauen.
Das könnten wir tatsächlich.
Das schreibe ich schon mal auf.
Gibt doch jetzt auch Doom auf einem Schwangerschafts-
Was?
Ernsthaft?
Sleeping Chris sagt, bei mir auf der Arbeit läuft Doom auf einem Xerox-Drucker.
Ja, wundert mich nicht.
Also gerade, es ist ja so das Hobby, Doom überall.
Es gibt auch die Leute mit Doom auf dem Taschenrechner und sowas.
Wieso?
Xerox ist immer noch, was Drucker angeht, ganz weit vorne.
Also vor allem in den USA ist Xerox.
In den USA ist es ja auch so, dass man nicht kopieren sagt, sondern irgendwie to Xerox.
Anstatt zu kopieren.
Die sagen nicht, dass sie irgendwie Copy machen.
Die sagen, die Xeroxen das.
Das ist bei denen so bekannt, der Name, dass das gleichbedeutend mit Drucken und Kopieren ist.
Trotz des Scanning-Bugs.
Oh, nee, ey.
Der Scan-Bug, das ist auch so ein Ding gewesen.
Den Vortrag können wir uns irgendwann mal anhören.
Das ist genau das.
Wie gibt man ein Tempo?
Oder...
Wenn früher für die Elfen...
Wenn früher für die Eltern alles Nintendo oder alles Playstation war.
Ich glaube, die meisten Eltern wissen heute noch nicht, dass es neben Playstation und Nintendo sowas wie eine Xbox gibt.
Oder noch zig, dass es zig andere Konsolen gegeben hat.
Die meisten Eltern kennen nur, wenn die Kinder ein bisschen älter sind, so wie ich.
Da war es noch Nintendo, so alles Nintendo.
Und bei allen, die ein bisschen jünger sind als ich, da war alles Playstation.
So.
Ich gucke mir jetzt mal ein bisschen Hardware von anderen Leuten an.
Da kann ich mich...
Da kann ich ein bisschen ablästern über die Hardware von anderen Leuten.
Das ist exzellent.
Wade.
Was mir wurde, der Channel hier empfohlen, ist das Seriously Max FPS.
Nein, das ist Max DPS.
Okay, das war ein ganz schlechter.
Das war Payne's Champions, Alter.
Wobei, ich habe jetzt tatsächlich einen Channel, der heißt sogar wirklich Max DPS.
Da wollte ich mal Overwatch-Videos drauf machen.
Und irgendwie zwei Monate später hat mich Overwatch abgefuckt.
Und ich habe keine Videos mehr gemacht.
Monarch S.
Außer, genau, außerdem ist das Wubblos.
So sieht es aus.
So, einmal kurz.
So, zeig her.
Erstmal ein bisschen weniger lautes Intro, please.
Da hat er schöne Sony Vegas Schrift-Presets genommen.
Hey, was geht's allen?
Das ist Rob Willis.info hier.
Ich, ganz ehrlich, ich frage mich immer, warum brauchen die Leute so viel Hardware?
Ich weiß nicht, ob der KeeperFX noch im Chat ist.
Ich weiß, der hat daheim auch irgendwie einen Ceph-Cluster von, frag mich nicht, wie vielen Kisten.
Wo ich mich immer frage, was machen die Leute damit?
Und genau so.
Ich meine, das Ding ist ein bisschen größer als mein Rack.
Also, wie gesagt, ich zeige es dir jedes Mal zum Vergleich.
Warum ist das so kacke ausgelöscht?
Wahrscheinlich, weil es...
So, das ist...
Da ist ja außer die 4 HE-Kiste, die jetzt aus ist,
nichts wirklich Weltbewegendes drin, außer eine USV,
einem Switch und ein paar kleinen, bisschen kleinen Scheiß.
Ja, da ist ja ein Händchen-Grenzen.
So, das Rack von dem ist ein Ticken größer.
Hat irgendwie sehr merkwürdige Beleuchtung.
Oder die Kamera ist schlecht, eins von beiden.
Oder es sieht cool aus, dass er hier oben so eine Leuchte drangemacht hat, was auch immer.
Ich frage mich, was die Leute damit machen.
Weil eins ist ja mal klar.
Der Scheiß ist laut und der Scheiß verbraucht Strom as fuck.
Ich meine, ich mag Hardware.
Ich finde das immer noch toll, durch dunkle Rechenzentren zu laufen
und mir die Hardware-Blinken anzusehen.
Ja.
Die Erkenntnis sehe ich mittlerweile ganz genauso.
Sehe ich mittlerweile ganz genauso.
Die Erkenntnis übrigens.
Ein absolut exquisiter Name.
Die Erkenntnis schreibt, wie sich das anhört im Chat,
so als hätte es jetzt irgendwie, als wären wir erleuchtet, ja.
Schreibt im Chat, ich habe vier Raspberry Pis und ein Otoid im Netzwerk.
Was braucht man mehr?
Wahrscheinlich gar nichts.
Ja.
Also ich bin ja mittlerweile auch von einer fetten 4AE-Kiste weg
auf mehrere kleine Sachen, die sich um spezielle Sachen kümmern.
Um spezielle Dinge jeweils kümmern.
Das eine macht irgendwie Kameras und UniFi-Controller.
Das andere macht Aufnahme von Kabel, Fernsehen.
Das andere macht Bodenfeuchtigkeit von Blumen auf der Terrasse und im Hof.
Und solche Geschichten, ja.
Also der PFSense wird abgelöst durch den MikroTik-Router.
Ja, also ich bin da mittlerweile auch eher auf dem, darauf, dass ich sage,
okay, ich mache lieber ein paar Sachen mehr einzeln
und dafür ist nicht alles kaputt, sobald eine Sache weg ist.
Vor allem ist es meistens auch so,
dass trotz, dass man, es klingt erstmal widersprüchlich, ne,
man denkt sich so, man baut eine Kiste für alles, also hat man weniger Aufwand.
Aber diese eine Kiste durch das Zusammenspiel der vielen Sachen, die drauf sind,
wird so viel komplizierter, dass es mehr Aufwand ist,
als fünf kleine Sachen hinzustellen, an denen du kaum was machen musst.
Es klingt erstmal widersprüchlich, dass man fünf kleine Sachen hinstellt,
dass sie nicht so aufwendig sind wie eine, oder auch zehn Sachen.
Ich meine, ich habe ja ein paar ESP32-Controller und so,
oder sonst was im Haus verteilt.
Die Dinger habe ich einmal geflasht mit irgendeiner Firma,
die halbwegs tut, was ich da zusammengewurstet habe,
obwohl es C++ ist.
Das ist zwar ein Widerspruch in sich, aber irgendwie scheint es zu gehen.
Und seitdem laufen die und da mache ich nichts dran.
Hast du eine gute Anleitung parat, wie man bei einem MikroTik-Router IPv6 bekommt?
Wenn man da vorne auch eine FRITZ!Box hat,
die DSL-Verbindung herstellt und DHCPv6,
also eigentlich muss man mit IPv6 gar keine IPv6 haben.
Das kann man normalerweise alles den Geräten selbst überlassen.
Also man braucht gar keine.
Aber wenn die FRITZ!Box DHCP macht,
nein, ich habe noch keinen DHCP6-Client auf MikroTik eingerichtet.
Ich würde aber vermuten, dass das genauso simpel ist wie ein IPv4-Client.
Habe ich aber noch nicht gemacht.
IPv4-DHCP-Client ist einfach.
Da gehst du ins Webinterface,
gehst auf IP, gehst auf DHCP,
gehst auf DHCP-Client und richtest das ein.
Da musst du irgendwie noch das Interface auswählen.
Übrigens Leute, ich habe letztens,
ich weiß, ich bin spät dran,
ich habe letztens erst kapiert,
warum DHCP,
warum IPv4 und IPv6,
IPv4 und IPv6 heißen.
Ich meine, dass das mehr Adressen sind
und dass das eine 32,
ne, er zählt jetzt 8,
ne, 32 Bit und das andere,
äh,
gar nicht, wie viel sind das andere,
warte mal,
wie viel sind IPv6?
128?
Naja, wie auch immer,
mir ist das letztens erst eingefallen,
weil ich ein bisschen rumgebastelt habe
und,
ähm,
auf so einem Arduino-Ding
und da musste ich
ein bisschen RAW-TCP-Verbindung und sowas machen
und da habe ich probiert, okay,
jetzt gebt doch mal die IP aus,
ähm, für
den Client,
der sich gerade connected hat
und da ist mir zum ersten Mal eingefallen,
dass das ja
bei IPv4,
dass du quasi
4 mal 8,
ähm,
Blöcke hast für die IP-Adresse
und deswegen heißt das IPv4,
da bin ich erst mal drauf gekommen,
da habe ich mir gedacht, okay,
das haben ja andere wahrscheinlich vor, äh,
45 Jahren schon verstanden, aber
mir ist das zum ersten Mal so richtig aufgefallen,
äh,
das, äh,
ich meine, da hat man jetzt nichts von, großartig,
ja, genau,
so, ich lässe da mal ein bisschen weiter
über andere Leute, Hardware,
OMG, ist das denn möglich, ein IT-Stream?
Ich flippe aus, wieso machen wir das öfters?
Wir machen teilweise sogar noch viel abgedrehtere Sachen,
ja, übrigens, ich habe, ich habe eine Sache,
äh, wir haben ja letztens im Stream hier
den Ayaya-Controller programmiert,
der erinnert euch vielleicht noch,
und, ähm,
ich habe mal probiert,
weil, also ich muss dazu sagen,
ich habe es ja so programmiert,
dass man sein, äh,
sein ESP32-Firmware-Update
über das WLAN hochladen kann,
halt nicht, dass der Controller
sich das abruft, sondern dass man das hochladen kann,
und ich war
mit nichts zufrieden, was es gab,
der ESP32
eingebaute Webserver,
der ist rein single-threaded
und, äh,
spackt übelst rum, während, wenn man was anderes macht,
während man uploadet,
und, ähm, das andere Projekt,
was ich auf GitHub gefunden habe,
der deadloggt sich immer,
wenn man Pech hat,
so, und deswegen habe ich jetzt mal
vor ein paar Tagen probiert,
so einen Minimal-HTTP-Server selbst zu basteln,
der nichts kann, der kann, äh,
statische Webseite get ausliefern
und kann unter slash update
äh, einen Post-Request annehmen,
sonst kann der nichts, ja, mehr muss der aber auch nicht können,
ich muss sagen, es war auf der einen Seite einfacher,
als ich gedacht habe, also 100%ig funktionieren tut's
auch noch nicht, und auf der anderen Seite
sind, auf der anderen Seite sind mir ein paar Sachen
eingeleuchtet, die ich vorher noch nie kapiert habe,
unter anderem, mit wie viel Bytes das dann wirklich
bei einer IP-Adresse unter der Haut, ich meine,
ich wusste es die ganze Zeit schon, aber
so wirklich realisiert habe ich es jetzt erst,
das können wir im Stream mal nachbauen,
da bauen wir einen Mini-HTTP,
einen Mini-Web-Server
auf einem ESP32,
aber,
Moment, Moment, Moment,
Mini-SSL-Web-Server
auf einem ESP32
normaler Web-Server
ist ja, Moment,
ja, wir machen das mit SSL,
ansonsten wäre das zu langweilig,
ein einfacher DHCP-Server ist wirklich einfach,
das sind 5 Zeilen, Listen-Socket
und schmeißt irgendwie HTTP 200
ok, sonst was zurück,
das ist einfach, mit TLS wird's ein bisschen
schwieriger, aber das machen wir mal im Stream.
Hast du eine gültige
Domain für dein Heimnetzwerk,
ja, ich habe 2 Stück, aber ich verwende aktuell nur eine,
äh,
Domains sind auch so günstig, dass ich jedem
empfehlen kann, sich eine eigene Domain zu holen,
weil wenn man eine eigene Domain hat,
ist das mit Zertifikaten auch
relativ,
relativ einfach,
man kann das mit irgendeinem dünnen DNS-Zeug machen
und so, klar, geht auch,
aber dann hat man irgendwie eine ewig lange Adresse,
die einfachste,
die einfachste Variante ist tatsächlich,
sich für 5 Dollar
im Monat, äh, 5 Dollar im Jahr
äh,
nein, ich implementiere nicht selber das TLS,
das mach ich nicht, ich verwende
die Low-Level-TLS-Libraries,
die im ESP32 dabei sind,
nein, nein, nein, ich mach kein eigenes TLS,
das kannst du vergessen,
vor allem schon, vor allem erstens schon mal geil,
und Stream, und auch, da bin ich auch viel zu
Low-Brain für, das krieg ich nicht hin,
das muss ich mir erst mal nach 5 Monaten angucken,
dass ich irgendwie so einen ersten Handshake
vielleicht hinkriege, keine Ahnung,
nein, wir verwenden das da,
das da, das ist ein Microcontroller-TLS-Library,
das ist ein Microcontroller-TLS-Library,
das muss man trotzdem noch mehr oder weniger alles selbst machen,
also zumindest das Handling von den
Connections und sowas,
so, wir gucken uns das jetzt mal an,
oh, guck mal, der hat eine, nee, das ist keine Konsole,
oder ist das eine Konsole, oder ist das einfach ein Monitor,
der im Rack steht, ich glaub, das ist einfach ein Monitor,
der im Rack steht, und wenn ich da schon sehe,
dass da irgendein Windows-Gedöns ist,
Painschamp,
ach nee, das ist von 2013,
sein altes Setup,
oder hat er einen
ESX-Home installiert, gerade,
hast du einen KVM-Switch, ja,
verwende ich aber nicht,
ach so, nee,
einen KVM-Switch habe ich nicht,
ich habe einen Remote-KVM,
also sprich, das ist so ein Teil,
stoppst den Netzwerkkabel rein,
Seite an VGA und USB dran
und dann kannst du per Browser an jeden Server-Remote
dran, wo das dran steckt. Das ist ja
quasi ein KVM-Switch,
halt über IP ohne Switch
für mehrere Server. Ne, einen richtig
großen KVM-Switch habe ich nicht.
Was, ihr müsst in der Ausbildung gerade
Windows-Server aufsetzen? Ich habe erstmal eine Runde
geheult, ja, das kann ich verstehen.
Ich meine, er hat so eine,
die Beleuchtung erinnert mich ein bisschen an die
Straßenlampe, so.
Ist deine Domain auch außerhalb
deines Netzwerks erreichbar?
Ja. Auflösbar ist sie,
glaube ich.
Auflösbar ist sie,
aber
außerhalb erreichbar ist sie nicht.
Also wir können es ja, Moment,
wie macht man einen Dick unter
Windows?
NS-Lookup, hä?
Wobei das,
ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert. Moment, ich mache mal kurz
meinen Linux-Fireman.
Da können wir gucken, ob meine Domain überhaupt
von außen richtig auflösbar ist. Keine Ahnung.
Muss sie, ne, muss sie ja.
Sie muss ja von außen auflösbar
sein, weil ich kann mir ja
Zertifikate ausstellen für
meine Domain. Da muss sie ja von außen
auflösbar sein.
Ich gucke mal, ich gucke mal, was da rauskommt.
Also nehmen wir mal
zum Beispiel mal einen Staubsauger.
Staubsauger ist der her.
Staubsauger.
Ja, der
Staubsauger hat Root-Zugang per SSH und
Web-Interface.
Das ist, das sorgt ja immer im Stream für Begeisterung.
Ähm, so,
jetzt gucken wir mal. Dick.
Äh, also dick.
Geh, geh, geh.
Kein Gachi-Bass, dick.
Dick. Äh,
Moment, ich kann nicht tippen.
So, was sagt der Google-DNS dazu?
Der Google-DNS sagt dazu,
Cloudflare ist zuständig. Das ist richtig.
Ich mache DNS über Cloudflare.
Beziehungsweise ich lasse das über Cloudflare
laufen, weil Cloudflare
als einziger
äh, ne, stimmt nicht, löscht das
einziger im Vergleich zu meinem Domain-Anbieter
eine ordentliche API
für DNS-Änderungen hat.
Und ich brauche, ähm,
Bing Weekly News
Piss dich, Alter.
Wie geht das? Wie geht das weg?
Wie, wie, wie geht das weg?
Das ist die Domain.
Die heißt halt so.
Die genaue Bedeutung muss ich euch jetzt ja nicht
erklären. Die Domain heißt halt einfach so.
Genau wie es google.de gibt.
Ah, gut, jetzt bin ich wenigstens weg.
Nein, du könntest
über das Web nicht auf meinen Staubsauger.
Das hat ja auch mit Domains nichts zu tun, sondern, ähm,
guck mal, wenn man hier auflöst,
ach, der löst, ach, guck mal,
der löst extern gar nicht auf.
Der, der kennt das Ganze nicht.
Ne, ne, der löst gar nicht auf.
Erklär uns bitte die Bedeutung von was?
Nö.
Erklär ich euch nicht.
Das ist meine Domain.
Gibt keinen Versand, warum die so heißt.
Naja, komm, die, die, die Erklärung ist doch
relativ naheliegend. Punkt Haus,
weil ich das für meine Hausautomatisierung gekauft
hab. So. Und
Mau wegen der Katz.
Also das ist quasi Katzenhaus
äh
et, ne, also
das, das, das
Mau wegen Katz und Haus, weil es für Heimatomatisierung ist.
Das hat keinen tieferen Sinn, die Domain.
Und weil die halt billig war, ne.
Kost, kost mich, glaube ich, 3 Dollar
oder sowas im Jahr.
Kenngin, moin. Kann es sein, dass
Cloudflare Free Model nur HTTP
und HTTPS-Anfragen verarbeitet hat?
Hat das in anderen Anwendungen versucht, aber funktioniert nicht?
Fragt der Calimero09.
Kein Schimmer. Ich benutze Cloudflare
auch nicht zum Durchleiten. Ich benutze
von Cloudflare nur den DNS und den kann man
kostenlos verwenden.
Ich leite meinen Traffic
nicht durch Cloudflare durch.
Ist auch überhaupt nicht notwendig, weil ich gar nichts von
außen habe. Rein intern.
Das einzige, was von außen
irgendwie
auflösbar ist, ist
meine Domain.
Und
Cloudflare ist auch nur dafür da,
dass ich eben Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate
ausstellen kann. Wo hast du die Domain
gekauft? Bei
irgendeinem Billighaus da.
Ist aber auch egal. Du kannst die bei jedem x-beliebigen
x-beliebigen Domain-Registrar
kaufen. Da kostet alles nix.
Großartig, ne. Du kannst auch, keine Ahnung,
wenn du was deutsches hast, kannst du irgendwie
Hetzner-Domain oder so gucken.
Der Kram, also ich hab's nicht bei Hetzner gekauft,
der Kram kostet nix. Also sagen wir jetzt mal irgendwie,
wir wollen, was wollen wir jetzt mal kaufen?
Irgendwie, gucken wir mal irgendwie
nach einer Domain hier.
Cute-Chat. Mal gucken, was es da für Domains gibt.
Cute-Chat alle. So.
Moment, wie funktioniert das? Punkt Bayern.
Wollen wir schon immer,
ich wollte schon immer mal Cute-Chat Punkt Bayern haben.
So. Es gibt ja
30 Milliarden
Domains, ey.
Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Oh, das war bei Hetzner jetzt nicht.
Na gut, das sind die, die Punkt
Bayern. Die wollen Cute-Chat Punkt
Bayern ernsthaft 38
Euro? What the fuck?
Warum ist das so teuer bei Hetzner-Domain?
Die ganzen Müll brauchen wir doch nicht.
Okay.
Also ich hab's bei denen
gekauft, allerdings,
ähm,
naja, mal ehrlich, so toll
ist der Anbieter nicht. Wie gesagt, keine DNS-API
und noch was. Ja,
da bewegen wir uns schon in Regionen.
Was sagt er? Domains
saubillig.de.
Okay, das klingt jetzt allerdings eher nach
äh, Scam.
Domainsaubillig.de. Aber wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich gibt's die Seite wirklich, äh.
Das gibt's ernsthaft, äh.
Domainsaubillig.de.
Big Brain-Domain. Okay.
Gucken wir mal.
Cute-Chat. Das ergibt überhaupt
keinen Sinn.
www ist das Sub-Domain.
Okay, der Domain-Anbieter hat schon mal keine Ahnung,
wie der Kram überhaupt funktioniert. So.
Cute-Chat.
Muss ich das wirklich komplett, komplett eingeben?
Ja, das ist ja doof.
Äh, Punkt, keine Ahnung, AT.
WW. Warum
WWW? Das ist
absolut unsinnig, wenn man
eine Domain kaufen will, noch eine Sub-Domain anzugeben.
Wozu? Okay, aber
billig ist es echt.
Also, billig ist es wirklich.
Cute-Chat.AT.
Okay, also, das muss
man ihnen wirklich lassen. Billig sind sie.
Ich mein, guckt euch mal. Ein Moment. Monatlich.
Monatlich.
Nee, da geht's. Da geht's doch eigentlich. Ich mein, guckt mal.
Ich hab hier, ich bezahl hier für die Domain im Jahr.
Gut, das ist
das erste Jahr. Das sind so, so, so irgendwelche
Log-Angebote.
Cute-Chat.at. Wir gucken jetzt mal die gleiche Domain, die ich,
die ich mir auch mal so, oder? So.
Oh.
Zehn Euro im Jahr.
Kostet mittlerweile anscheinend.
Allerdings ist es auch dann kein großer Unterschied
zu hier. Ich mein, das musst du mal zwölf rechnen.
Wobei, sowas ist natürlich, Moment.
Cute-Chat.de
kostet nur 19,
19 Cent?
Was?
Ist das nur,
ist das nur ein G-Baid-Angebot?
Warum sind die E-Domains
zu billig?
Niemand mag die E. Das wär mir ganz ehrlich
für, für meine private Domain vollkommen
egal. Äh.
Hä? Moment.
Hä? Die, die Rechnung
versteh ich nicht.
Gesamtkosten?
Ach so, ah, ah. Monatlich.
Ach so. Okay, ah, ja, verstehe.
Also sprich,
ähm.
Also sprich, ähm.
90, hallo?
Ich will ein Komma machen, 0,90.
90.
Windows, please.
0, 0.
Sag mal.
Hä?
Ah, das gibt's, gibt's, gibt's in der Prok-
Äh, okay. Mal
zwölf.
Ja, okay, dann passt das.
Geht eigentlich.
Was bezahl ich denn hier für Cute-Chat.de?
Ach nee, na, äh, was?
Nein.
Ich will Cute, nicht net, net,
Dings, Chat.
Cute-Chat.de.com.
Alles klar. Ach, guck mal, die dürfen keine
DE verkaufen. Punkt lol.
Gibt das Punkt lull?
Punkt lull?
Ah.
Also das ist günstig, echt günstig.
Zumindest ist auch, es ist, es ist
vollkommen, es ist vollkommen egal,
ähm, wo ihr eure
Domain kauft. Guck mal, bei Headstamp wird's sogar
elf, elf Euro kosten, ist relativ teuer da.
Ähm, egal, wo ihr eure Domains
kauft, ihr könnt danach einfach sagen,
okay, ähm, umstellen
Nameserver auf,
auf
Cloudflare und gut ist.
Und dann ist, äh,
soll ich mal gucken, ob es Cute-Chat.kegw
gibt?
Ah.
Wie, es gibt nicht kegw als Top-Level-Domain?
Was ist da los?
Was, was soll das?
Gibt's das Punkt lull?
Ha. Gibt's nicht.
Anzeige ist raus, ja.
Was ist?
kegw.
Es gibt, es,
es gibt keine kegw als Top-Level-Domain.
Da bin ich
jetzt, äh, echt enttäuscht.
Ja.
Aber unabhängig davon, wo ihr euch die Domain
kauft, danach könnt ihr einfach,
also wenn euer Anbieter sagt,
dass der keine ordentliche API für den DNS hat,
Punkt pepega.
Ja, ganz bestimmt, wenn's kein keg.
Oh, ne. Aber es gibt
cute-chat-pepega.com
für 4 Euro im Jahr.
Aber ich muss sagen, das hier sieht
wirklich echt günstig aus.
Ich glaube, ich probiere das nachher
mal aus. Ich meine, ich werde mir nicht unbedingt
Cute-Chat kaufen.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, man kann sich ja auch mit Fake-Daten
registrieren und sowas. Ich meine, offiziell
darf man es ja nicht, ne.
Also eigentlich darf man bei Domains keine
Fake-Daten eingeben. Aber mal ganz im Ernst.
Warum nicht?
Der Anbieter, den interessiert's nicht.
Hauptsache, ihr bezahlt.
Und im Zweifelsfall, das Schlimmste, was
euch passieren kann, ist, dass sie euch nicht
erreichen und irgendwie ihr die Domain nicht
bekommt. Aber who cares, ja.
Habe mit deinem
Traffic-Video das ganze Ding zum Laufen
gebracht. Ja, exzellent.
Sehr schön. So, jetzt gucken wir uns das Video
erstmal fertig an. Wir haben jetzt genug gelabert.
... für eine Hosting-Company
und ein SMB-Segment.
Und viele der Kunden hatten nur
ihre Produktion gesetzt.
Die Video-Qualität ist übelst
mühle.
... so we'd often run into issues that were
large and complex enough that we couldn't really
troubleshoot them in real time because, like I said, the services
are live, this is the production environment,
we can't reboot it, we can't
take services down. So basically
I would try and replicate those issues
on my own home environment, assuming it was
something generic like IIS, MSSQL
or something like that. Zu leise?
But basically I would
try and replicate the issues on my own home
environment and then if I could, then I could just work
on it in my own time.
... and freely reboot the servers and all that stuff.
... and see if I could figure out the issue.
Moment, zeigt der uns hier...
Wie er aufrüstet!
Das ist Ikea!
Das ist das Ikea-Rack, oder? Ist das Ikea-Rack?
Nee, das ist ein richtiges.
Es gibt ja Leute,
die sagen sich, ey, warum soll ich mir ein Rack kaufen?
Die machen das mit einem Ikea-Schrank.
... die machen das mit einem Ikea-Schrank.
Und das funktioniert... 19-Zoll-Ikea-Schrank.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Inches. Inches.
Inches. Ja, meinetwegen.
Genau. Die nehmen so...
Die nehmen so 19-Zoll oder
ungefähr 19-Zoll breites Ikea-Zeug
und stecken das Zeug rein.
Das ist schon...
Ach ja, ihr könnt übrigens auch
19-Zoll-Audio-Racks nehmen.
Das passt theoretisch auch.
Aber das ist doch mal was, oder?
Es ist auch... Letztendlich ist es ja
dem System vollkommen wurscht.
Also, wenn man sich so ein richtiges Rack
kauft, wo man dann auch bei den passenden
Höhleneinheiten die Schrauben hat und sowas,
das ist einfach nur nice to have.
Laufen tun die Kisten
auch im Ikea-Rack oder auch
aufeinander gestapelt. Also brauchen
tut das eigentlich keiner.
Was ist das? Was ist das allein schon jetzt für
Stromfrist?
Übrigens, was man daran
sieht, ist, dass die...
Ne, man sieht es gar nicht.
Ja, VGA.
Das ist das.
Okay, das ist jetzt auch von 2014.
Das ist das, was ich jetzt immer sage.
Die fangen jetzt
erst an, seit
noch nicht lange,
seit relativ kurzer Zeit,
dass Server irgendwie
mal
was anderes als VGA als Ausgang
haben. Das gibt's noch nicht
lange. Also,
gerade bei so Enterprise-Hardware,
und Rechenzentrums-Einsatzgeschichten,
die meisten Dinger machen
absolut Oldschool-Eindruck.
Da hast du VGA-Ausgänge,
da hast du serielle
Schnittstellen teilweise noch vorne dran, da hast du
teilweise noch optische
Laufwerke dran, USB-2
und sonst was.
Das liegt aber auch unter anderem
daran, weil die ganze Infrastruktur im Rechenzentrum
drumherum, sei es irgendwelche KVM-Switch
und sonst was eben halt für VGA ist.
VGA hat glaube ich fast, fast
immer noch,
jede Kiste, ich hab mir jetzt unsere neuesten
Kisten nicht angeguckt, aber die meisten haben bestimmt immer noch
VGA, aber die haben
mittlerweile auch neuere, neuere
Dinger.
Wenn man das braucht,
wenn du mal an die Konsole, also wenn du mal
an den Server dran musst, weil da vielleicht
Remote nicht mehr erreichbar ist,
die haben zwar alle
ein Remote-Management-Interface, aber wenn das
wirklich nicht funktioniert, dann hast du als zweite
Möglichkeit immer noch, du gehst mit einem Wagen,
da ist halt ein Monitor, eine Tastatur,
drauf, da hin und stöpselst
dich an. Oder aber du hast
so ein komplettes KVM-Switch-System
im Rechenzentrum,
wo du dann
vielleicht einmal anstöpseln musst
und dann in den Seitenraum gehen kannst und
hast es dann auch da auf dem Monitor.
Jo Jim, 14 Monate. Oh, excellent.
14 Monate, das ist ja schon hier.
Ja.
So, ist das eigentlich seit
Jahrzehnten schon, ne?
Und die Dinger sind auch schon ein bisschen älter.
Ja.
Oh, Windows.
Wenn du was mit Home-Server sehen willst,
schau dir mal bei YouTube
My Playhouse an.
My Playhouse klingt irgendwie so ein bisschen nach Gachi,
Gachi-Buzz. Schick mal einen Link,
dann kannst du da kommen.
Was, El?
Ah, Elasticsearch.
Mein Gott, mittlerweile hat alles irgendwelche Abkürzungen.
Ich flipp aus.
Also entweder werde ich zu alt,
ich mein, ich bin immerhin schon 36 mittlerweile,
ich hab gestern, ich bin mittlerweile
so alt, dass ich schon aus Versehen 37
gestern auf Twitter geschrieben hab, aber ich bin ja erst 36.
Also ich blicke
bei den ganzen Abkürzungen mittlerweile nicht mehr durch.
Ich
komm meistens noch drauf,
aber es gibt
für jeden Scheiß
mittlerweile
irgendwelche Abkürzungen.
Und
also wenn,
vor allem ist das meiste nach einem Jahr schon
immer angesagt.
...Analysis against my own penetration tests
und es hilft mir wirklich zu wachsen.
Ich hatte letztens,
ich weiß immer noch nicht übrigens genau, wie es dazu
gekommen ist, ich hatte letztens Termin
mit einem, äh,
äh, was ist,
was ist er denn, ähm, Abteilungs-,
irgendwas, eine Stufe
unterm, unterm, unterm, äh,
Vorstandsmann, ähm,
also irgendwie
Abteilungsdirektor oder sowas,
der hat neu angefangen und, äh,
hat mich irgendwie eingeladen
zu einem Termin. Also man muss sich mal vorstellen,
irgend so ein Kerl im Organigramm,
äh, quasi, äh,
nur noch, nur noch unterm Vorstand,
äh, lädt irgendwie so, so einen random
IT-Mensch ein, ja. Und, äh,
äh, hat mich eingeladen
und wollte dann irgendwie Sachen wissen, wie's,
wie wir so, wie wir so Sachen in der
Firma machen. Das ist übrigens auch sinnvoll gewesen
im Nachhinein betrachtet, ja.
Also, ähm, er hat gemeint,
er kriegt auf seiner Management-Ebene halt
das schlecht mit und, äh, wird halt einfach
mal so gerne von Leuten hören, wie der Laden so
tickt. Und ich wurde ihm da irgendwie, äh,
empfohlen. Ich mein, spricht, spricht
jetzt ja irgendwie auch ein bisschen für mich,
ja, dass das, wenn, wenn da jemand
sagt, ja, der, der Max, der kann das, ähm,
der kann sowas gut
erklären, das ist ja auch ganz cool.
Und, ähm, da wollte ich jetzt drauf raus.
Genau. Und der hat wirklich,
du, du merkst, dass der, äh, früher
viel Start-Up-Gedöns
am Start war. Der ist
der Buzzword-Bingo-Mann-Extreme.
Der, der haut da echt
die Dinger raus am, am laufenden Band,
ey. Irgendwelche
Abkürzungen und, und Business-
Slang-Geschichten.
Der ist,
der ist wirklich Hyper-Stonks.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich war wirklich enorm
positiv überrascht. Normalerweise
ist es ja bei uns eher so,
dass die, ähm, oder wahrscheinlich
bei den meisten Unternehmen, denk ich mal,
dass so, äh, Abteilungsleiter,
Vorstandsleute und so, dass die
zwar schon, es ist nicht so, dass
die jetzt irgendwie, äh, wenn man den
Mann im Gang über den Weg läuft, dass die nicht
Hallo sagen oder so. Kann man nicht sagen. Aber, äh,
viele versuchen
eine gewisse Art von Autorität
auszustrahlen, indem sie,
es ist, es ist
schwer zu sagen,
halt, ja, wie soll
man das beschreiben?
Halt einem das Gefühl geben, ein bisschen,
ein bisschen drüber, drüber zu
sein, ja. Und, ähm,
das ist ja was, womit
ich persönlich nicht, nicht wirklich klar,
also, ich hab's ja, ich hab's ja schon öfters
erzählt, ich tu mir,
mit, äh,
autoritärem, nee, wie nennt
man das, ähm, ja doch,
so Auftreten irgendwie schwer. Ich mein,
klar, wenn ich von der Polizei angehalten
werden sollte oder irgendwas, da sag ich nicht,
oh, scheiß Polizei, dann, dann mach ich mit,
ja, weil ich keinen Bock hab, dass die mich einsacken.
Nee, aber, äh, einfach
nur so diese Sache, ähm,
ich bin besser, weil
ich im Organigramm oben steh, das,
da hab ich so, so, da
bin ich nicht so überzeugt von, deswegen ist
es immer auch schwierig, dann manche Sachen
einfach zu akzeptieren, wenn das einer sagt.
So, da hab ich so ein bisschen, bisschen
Schmerzen mit, weiß nicht, das ist so,
so quasi, ich bin besser, nur weil ich den
besseren Titel habe, zieht bei mir irgendwie nicht.
Zumindest, ähm, hat damit jetzt überhaupt
nichts zu tun, ähm, ich muss
sagen, ich war da echt extrem positiv,
positiv von überrascht,
der hat ganz, äh, dann erstens ganz normal mit einem,
ähm,
geredet, ja,
und, äh, du hattest tatsächlich den
Eindruck, der redet halt so,
mit, mit dir,
weil er sich dafür interessiert,
und nicht so nach dem Motto, äh,
zwischendurch immer so nach dem Motto, ja, aber
auf meiner Management-Ebene, da ist das ja ganz
anders oder so, irgendwie sowas, nee, du hattest
wirklich den Eindruck, den interessiert das wirklich.
Also ich war da unglaublich positiv von überrascht,
dass, äh, dass, dass wir dort
immer, immer mehr, muss man ja
sagen, immer mehr, ganz
normale Leute in, äh, den oberen
Führungspositionen haben. Weil man
muss ja auch mal ganz, wenn man, wenn man die Sache
ganz nüchtern betrachtet,
ähm,
ist es ja auch gar nicht
so. Das ist so ein bisschen, das hat sich so
die letzten, ja, keine Ahnung, Jahrhunderte,
Jahrzehnte, hat sich das ja immer so ein bisschen
eingeschleift. Also wenn das jetzt nicht grad
derjenige ist, der die Firma gegründet hat,
ja, dann sind das ja ganz normale
Angestellte auch. So.
Die haben, die haben schlicht und ergreifend andere Aufgaben.
So, und, äh, das
ist, setzt sich auch
immer, immer mehr durch.
Ja. Also der Chef ist
nicht in dem Sinn der Chef, weil er
nicht dafür irgendwie, so nach dem
Motto, ah, der Chef erzählt immer unqualifiziertes
Zeug und man muss es dann machen. Ne, ähm,
der Chef ist dafür
da, quasi die Sachen zu planen
und so dafür zu sorgen,
dass man seine Arbeit machen kann. Also die
Aufgaben sind einfach schlicht und ergreifend anders,
anders verteilt. Und wenn man das
Pech hat, quasi irgendwo zu
sein, wo das, ähm, noch, noch auf
die Oldschool, der Oldschool
Weg läuft, so nach dem Motto, der
Unfähigste wird jetzt der Chef, weil man ihn
fachlich nicht braucht und geht
dann allen auf den Sack, dann ist, dann
wird es den Laden auch wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
lange geben. Äh, genau, aber
MB-Dealer, das war so, das wird,
aber das wird weniger. Zumindest
habe ich bei uns den Eindruck, ähm,
weil man kann sich ja auch ehrlich gesagt
nicht, ähm,
da jetzt allzu viel
drauf einbilden. Das ist einfach eine andere
Position, wo man andere, wo
andere Fähigkeiten erforderlich sind.
Ja, ich hätte beispielsweise auf irgendwelche
Management-Stonks-Geschichten
absolut keinen Bock. Da muss man auch
ein anderer, ein anderer Typ sein, das zu
machen. Ja, ähm, zumindest
muss ich sagen, das war
echt nice, ja, also
du könntest dein Nextcloud durch Apache
Webdev ablösen, könnt ich machen, ja. So, ich muss
jetzt erst mal das Video fertig gucken. Ich labere jetzt schon ewig rum.
Wir haben 2 Minuten 40 Video geguckt. Da
fuck!
eBay!
Ja gut, eBay ist nicht schlecht für alte Server-Hardware.
eBay ist wirklich gut für so alte, alte ausgemogene
Muster der RZ-Hardware.
Es, es, es, es, es lookt ein bisschen besser beleuchtet
jetzt.
Äh, warum er hier oben die Straßenlaterne
dran hat, ist mir immer noch nicht ganz klar.
Hat der da hinten irgendwie,
ist das da ein Luft, Luftaustausch, irgendwie
Luftabzug, Klimaanlage oder was der da hinten dran hat?
Hat der da hinten wirklich ein Ab, ein Ab, äh, Luft?
Was, ich kratze am Mikro?
Hä? Leute, kratze ich am Mikro irgendwie?
Gerade?
Sollte eigentlich nicht sein, vielleicht ist es nicht richtig drin.
Hat sich irgendwie am Mikro.
Also ich bin, ich, ich bin eben, ich
hab eben das Mikro eingestellt hier
jetzt.
Ich hab eben das Mikro richtig am Mund gemacht, aber ansonsten...
Ich mach da manchmal, ich
ändere manchmal die Höhe.
...
Da unten hat er aber ordentlich Speicher drin.
Guck mal, das Video ist 1080p, aber das sieht aus wie 480.
Aber unten, da hat er wirklich massig Platten.
Guck mal, das sind 1, 2, 3.
Warte mal, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
6, 12, 18, 24.
Ne, doch.
24 Platten.
Das ist schon ordentlich, was da reinpasst.
Da unten könnten 2 DL380 oder irgendwie sowas sein.
Das würde überhaupt nicht in meinen Raum reinpassen.
Ja, das ist ja auch das Problem.
Das ist ja auch das Problem, dass der Kram übelst warm wird, wenn zu viel drin ist.
Das ist ja auch einer der Gründe, warum ich gesagt habe,
okay, das ist ja auch der Grund, warum ich gesagt habe,
ich will in meinen Raum gar nicht so viel reinmachen,
weil ich habe keinen Bock, eine extra Lüftung reinzubauen.
Das, was ich bei mir laufen habe, diese Geschichte hier,
das Einzige, was wirklich nennenswert Abwärme produziert hat,
ist die 4 HE-Kiste.
Und ich habe hier halt keinen Luftaustausch irgendwie drin.
Also sprich, ich könnte hier gar nicht viel mehr reinstellen in den Raum
oder es würde zu warm werden.
Ich würde hier nicht mehr reinstellen.
What?
Okay, das sieht äußerst behelfsmäßig aus.
Okay.
Warum hat er da so ein komisches Feld drüber gemacht?
Aber Hauptsache mal schön Klebe bandet.
This is the kind of fan that you would use in your bathroom
to exhaust like the shower.
But I have one of those inside there.
And there's a 6-inch flexible pipe that runs through the window.
And the whole thing has been wrapped in a blanket
to kind of insulate.
Also ob es das Tuch da jetzt groß bringt, habe ich meine Zweifel.
Einfach als Sauna verwenden.
Ja, super Idee.
Und dann auf die Technik schwitzen, oder was?
Painstrap.
Und das ist alles, was ich auf meinem Server habe.
Es ist nichts Fanziges.
Es ist sehr einfach, rechtzeitig und teuer, was es sein soll.
Und es hat mir tatsächlich sehr gut funktioniert.
Man kann damit ein bisschen rumspielen, aber ich bin der Meinung, wenn man einfach nur ein bisschen die Technik lernen möchte, also wie man zum Beispiel ein HA-Cluster einrichtet oder sowas, wenn es jetzt nicht gerade ESX sein soll, kann man sehr viel auch mit zwei, drei Raspberry Pis üben und die brauchen viel weniger Platz, die brauchen viel weniger Strom und die machen viel weniger Krach und sind viel weniger heiß.
Man kann sich auch ein paar Intel NUCs kaufen, wenn man was machen will, aber wenn man zum Beispiel mal einen Redis-Cluster machen will.
Oder ein bisschen Kubernetes-Gedöns basteln will oder mal eine Postgres mit Replikationen oder irgendwas machen will, da kann man einfach sich zwei, drei Raspberry Pis holen und damit rumbasteln und dann wieder ausschalten.
Also wenn man einfach lernen will, wie es geht, ist das, wenn man ehrlich ist, nicht notwendig.
Hier, das da.
Und ein paar VMs auf dem Desktop, ja.
Wobei ich...
Wobei ich sagen muss, alles mit VMs ist auch nicht gut, weil wenn man ein bisschen Netzwerk-Config noch machen möchte mit irgendwelchen VLANs und vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen was anderes als einfach einen TP-Link oder Netgear oder dann, wobei Netgear haben ja auch ein bisschen bessere, TP-Link-Switch dazwischen stecken möchte, dann ist es nicht verkehrt.
Man holt sich irgendwie einen MikroTik-Router, das ist ja schon von Feature-Sets her was, wo du verdammt viel mitmachen kannst und dann kann man das auch gleich netzwerktechnisch selbst einrichten.
Dann ist es mit VMs... Das geht auch, aber es ist schöner, wenn man da Kisten dranhängen kann.
Da kann man das mal wirklich nachstellen, wie es ist.
Es gibt verschiedene Varianten. Man kann es auch komplett offline machen, äh, nicht offline, man kann es auch komplett online machen.
Man kann sich auch DigitalOcean oder sonst wo drei Kisten hinstellen und danach wieder ausschalten. Geht ja auch alles.
0.5
Also, die Dell CS24 SEs sind alle beinahe die gleiche Hardware-weise konfiguriert.
Sie haben alle Dual-Quad-Cores, also 8-Cores-Total, 24 GB RAM und ein bisschen Miscellaneous.
Also, das erste hier, dieser Hypervisor, er hält...
Okay, dann mach da ESX drauf.
...mein primärer Feuerwall, welches das Gerät ist, in und aus dieser ganzen Stacke, und dann...
Ne, hä? Moment, noch, das muss ich mir nochmal anhören, das habe ich nicht kapiert.
Hast du PFSense im Heimnetzwerk?
Hatte ich, hatte ich. Als ich noch, äh, das meiste hier drauflaufen hatte, auf der, auf der, äh, 4-HE-Kiste, habe ich nicht mehr.
Ich habe das abgelöst durch nen...
Low...
...Budget, ich glaube, 50 Euro oder so, äh, MikroTik, MikroTik-Router.
Du kannst nicht ganz so viel, oder du kannst andere Sachen machen, also du kannst...
...viele, äh, so klassische Netzwerktechnik-Geschichten, wie irgendwelche...
...Routing-Protokoll-Sachen, WLANs und sowas, ist das Handling, finde ich.
Wobei, das WLAN-Handling von MikroTik ist kacke.
Aber so die, so die, die im Netzwerk-Vielfalt, was du machen kannst, ist bei MikroTik besser.
Allerdings, ähm, die Bedienung ist bei PFSense besser.
Und auch die Firewall-Funktion ist bei PFSense besser.
Äh, bei MikroTik hast du so ein behelfsmäßiges Firewall-Track-and-Drop-Menü.
Du machst bei beiden im Prinzip ja das Gleiche.
Ja, PFSense ist ja auch so ne stinknormale, äh, Stateful Firewall, wo du einfach sagst, hier, von da nach da...
...äh, Established-Verbindungen erlauben, nur dass PFSense eben, äh, BSD-Basis ist und MikroTik ist ganz...
...unten drunter irgendeine, irgendeine Linux-Geschichte, macht aber unterm Strich eigentlich keinen großen Unterschied.
Und, ähm, PFSense hat halt ein paar Features, die, äh, MikroTik nicht hat.
Ich glaub, bei MikroTik ist es zum Beispiel relativ schwierig, so nen WLAN-Portal einzurichten.
Das ist bei PFSense total einfach.
Und die Bedienung ist halt bei PFSense so gemacht, dass es auch jemand, äh, gut bedienen kann, der jetzt netzwerktechnisch nicht ganz so...
...proversiert ist, ja.
MikroTik geht auch.
Aber die haben da schon an manchen Stellen ein bisschen Eigenheiten, ja.
Zum Beispiel die WLAN-Config in, ähm, also VLAN-Config in MikroTik ist beknackt gelöst, ja.
Das hab ich bei, also das, das macht jeder andere Anbieter besser.
Ja, und ein Vorteil muss man da auch sagen, PFSense braucht halt irgendeine x86-Hardware, auf der es läuft.
Und MikroTik ist halt ein fertiges, äh, fertige Routerkiste, die man sich hinstellt und gut ist.
It holds two virtual machines for the most part.
My, äh, primary firewall, which is the gateway into and out of this entire stack, and then also has a full-time, äh, PCAP-Machine or packet capture.
Okay, hab ich das jetzt richtig verstanden?
Der hat hier oben drauf nen ESX installiert für zwei VMs.
Kann ein MikroTik-Router QoS-Traffic-Shaping? Ja, kann er.
Ähm, die, die, es gibt von, es gibt nen, ähm, ach, wie, wie heißt der andere Kram?
Open...
...WRT?
Lede, OpenWRT, die haben sich irgendwie gemerged jetzt.
Die haben nen richtig cooles Traffic-Shaping-Modul, da kann das von MikroTik nicht mithalten, was, äh, OpenWRT hat.
Aber das braucht man meistens auch gar nicht.
Also OpenWRT hat, äh, das ist eines der besten Features an OpenWRT, falls man das mal verwenden will,
ist ihr, ihr, ihre wirklich vielfältigsten Traffic-Shaping-Einstellungen.
Wobei man vieles in MikroTik auch machen kann, ja.
Also MikroTik hat auch unterschiedliche Q-Configs, so sprich, in welche Projekte, äh, Q-Configs.
werden, aber OpenWRT ist
noch ein Ticken, was
QoS angeht, noch ein Ticken
besser. Natürlich im Vergleich
zu irgendwie einer Fritzbox oder
so, ist das alles
alle mal besser dort einzustellen.
Bei PFSense
bin ich mir was QoS
Settings angeht, gar nicht mal so sicher mehr, was man da
alles machen konnte.
Aber habe ich das richtig verstanden? Der hat
auf der ersten Kiste
nur einen ESX mit zwei
VMs. Und eine
VM ist dafür da,
sein Router zu sein.
Okay?
Wirkt mir jetzt ein bisschen, oh was heißt
ich meine, er hätte einfach
sein PFSense einfach da drauf installieren können
und gut wäre gewesen.
Ähm, was war ansonsten?
Ja,
DomePC, das ist zwar bei PFSense
auch so und bei OpenWRT
je nach Router mit Sicherheit auch so.
Oder je nach unterstütztem Gerät garantiert auch so.
Ähm,
ja, also, ja, ist so.
Wobei ich mir nicht sicher bin,
ob es bei den
teureren Routern, die haben ja nicht nur
diese 50 Euro Einsteiger-Router, die haben ja auch
richtig fette, ob das da auch so ist
oder ob die einfach nur stark genügend CPU haben.
Zumindest für den Heimbereich,
da machst du ja vielleicht
zwei, drei QoS-Regeln und gut ist.
Und also ich habe insgesamt, glaube ich, um die
20 Firewall-Regeln für alles.
Also sprich, WLAN zu WLAN, intern
zu WLAN, nach außen von 20 Stück,
fertig.
Und, äh, damit kommt der Router
gut klar, die, dieser Mikro, die
50 Euro Mikro-Tick, äh, gedönst.
Wenn das jetzt irgendwie so ein super Business-Enterprise-Ding
wäre, mit was weiß ich,
2000 Regeln und Geschiss,
dann würde ich
das auch nicht mit dem 50-Euro-Router machen, ja.
Nee, du musst das, du musst das über
die interne CPU laufen lassen.
Ich denke nicht, dass es da irgendeine
äh, Hardware-Geschichte
gibt, die man nachrüsten kann.
Dass man das, aber das ist ja auch nicht schlimm.
Weil letztendlich,
ist es ja immer nur
ein Stück Hardware,
was die Sache ausführt.
Klar, du hast spezialisierte Hardware
für manche Sachen, die kann das natürlich sehr schnell
und auch meistens parallelisiert.
Ähm, aber es ist, es ist nicht schlecht,
wenn das jetzt, also es ist nicht schlechter,
wenn die CPU was berechnen muss,
als wenn du irgendwie eine dedizierte Hardware hast.
Ja, theoretisch ist das bei der anderen Sache einen Ticken
schneller, nicht, dass das irgendwie relevant wäre,
aber, ähm,
sobald du halt Auslastungsprobleme
bekommst, dann ist es halt doof,
weil dann kann deine CPU nichts anderes
mehr machen oder kommt halt nicht hinterher.
Schwache NAT und CoES-Performance
rausgeflogen. Also ich glaube, mein MikroTik
hat, hat standardmäßig irgendwie was, 15%
CPU-Last oder so.
Pika-Boo, Pika, Pika-Boo
TV. Twitch Prime,
Dankeschön, excellent Subscription.
Ähm, und man muss halt sagen,
PFSense, das läuft halt komplett auf x86
Hardware, wird alles CPU-mäßig gemacht.
Ich bin der Meinung, für
Heimanwendungssachen
ist das eigentlich ein Thema, das kann man
vernachlässigen. Es sei denn, man macht
wirklich super abgedrehte Sachen,
ähm, hat dann irgendwie massig
Firewall-Regeln, zig, zig QoS
Geschichten, was auch immer man noch alles machen
kann. VPN, VPN ist zum Beispiel
so eine Geschichte, ja. Äh,
VPN ist halt die Frage,
also mal angenommen, man möchte VPN verwenden
und man möchte, ähm,
das, das, viel
Bandbreite übers VPN kriegen,
dann ist halt die Frage, hat
die jeweilige, das ist auch, finde ich, eines der,
eines der wenigen Bereiche, wenn nicht der einzige
Bereich, wo das wirklich relevant ist, auch im
Heimbereich, ähm, hat die Hardware,
irgendwelche Hardware-Crypto-Extensions
oder nicht. Also, wenn man
sowas macht, wie nennen wir mal OpenVPN,
Wire, ähm, Dings,
nicht Wireshark,
wie heißt das andere, nicht, nicht OpenVPN,
Wire, Wire, Dings hier, ähm,
Wire, Wireguard, genau.
Äh, Wireguard
ist, äh, default-mäßig ein bisschen
performanter, aber nimm mal so einen Klassiker wie
OpenVPN. Ähm,
die haben das nur für, für,
für IPsec, ja, das
wundert mich nicht, wusste ich nicht.
Zumindest, ähm, die meisten
recht Budget
Hardware-Kisten, die machen,
die haben keine, äh,
Hardware-Extensions oder keine
genug Crypto-Extensions, dass man
OpenVPN, äh,
da großartig mit
mehreren Sessions mit viel, mit hoher
Bandbreite hinbekommt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es mit Wireguard auf
MikroTik aussieht, die haben ja ein eigenes
Plugin dafür, ähm,
da kriegt man jetzt nicht die Wahnsinns-Bandbreite
durch, aber es ist halt auch die Frage, wie man,
inwieweit man das braucht, also sprich,
mich mal, äh,
Remote einloggen
per OpenVPN
und, äh,
dann meinetwegen auch mal, wenn Leute,
ich weiß ja, dass hier viele Leute einen Black-Server laufen
haben, ich bin ja immer noch skeptisch, wofür man
einen Black-Server braucht, außer für die eine Sache,
an die wir jetzt alle denken, ähm,
man kann da auch ohne Probleme mal einen Film
übers VPN streamen, ja,
das braucht ja nicht so viel,
das ist, lass es mal 15, 15
Mbit sein, also je nachdem, wie das Ganze encoded
ist oder so, das kriegt man da
auch drüber, wenn man, vorausgesetzt, man
hat an sich schon genug Bandbreite,
aber, äh, wenn man jetzt sagt, okay,
ich nehme so einen 50-Euro-MikroTik-Router
für so Small-Business, für, für
ein, für ein kleines Büro,
ja, sagen wir mal, sagen wir mal, in der heutigen
Zeit wäre es so, jemand kauft sich so
einen, so einen, äh, so einen kleinen
MikroTik-Router, weil er sagt, okay,
die Leute müssen jetzt Remote arbeiten,
sind normalerweise irgendwie eine Fünfer-Werbe-Agentur,
oder so, fünf Mann, Werbe-Agentur, zehn Mann,
und, äh, die arbeiten jetzt alle
von daheim, so, und dann kommt irgendwie eine
an und richtet darauf VPN ein,
und es arbeiten zehn Leute per VPN,
das kannst du knicken,
ja, also ich würde sagen, zehn, ich würde
sogar schon sagen, bei zehn Leuten mit ordentlicher
Bandbreite wird's schon eng.
Ich hab's nie ausprobiert, das ist jetzt reine, reine,
ähm, Abschätzung.
Ich
kann's nicht sagen, ich hab's nicht ausprobiert, ja,
aber dafür würde ich sowas schon
nicht mehr nehmen, da würde ich mir irgendwas Besseres kaufen,
zumal, ähm, man sich eh
fragen muss, wenn man quasi
ein Büro hat mit zehn Leuten,
die arbeiten, kann man nicht ein bisschen mehr als
50 Euro für eine ordentliche Netzwerkgeschichte
ausgeben, ja, aber für
ich will mich mal von unterwegs
mit meinem Smartphone daheim
einloggen und, äh, schon mal
meine Klimaanlage einschalten.
Vollkommen ausreichend,
ja, juckt das Ding.
Kann MikroTik OpenVPN? Ja, die können
OpenVPN, IPsec und
mittlerweile auch WireGuard.
Da gab's irgendein Package, hab ich gesehen, ja.
Gibt's, gibt's mittlerweile. Ich bin mir relativ
sicher, dass es da, dass es mittlerweile
ein WireGuard-Package gibt.
Ist der, der, ist der
das hier? RB750,
ich hab keine Ahnung, was da für ein Routerboard drunter ist.
Also, ich schreib im Chat, einer der,
das ist einer der günstigen MikroTik-Router,
das der 40, 400 Mbit
packt, IPsec.
IPsec ist aber wahrscheinlich
auch teilweise Hardware-Encryption,
äh, OpenVPN ist meistens langsamer
als IPsec. Ich denk mal, OpenVPN,
da kriegst du eine ganze, äh, deutlich, deutlich weniger
durch. Aber wie gesagt,
für, für den Heimbereich, ähm,
reicht's allemal, keine Frage, überhaupt kein Ding.
So, jetzt mach ich schnell ein Video fertig, guck von dem Typ.
Warum hat der so viele
4Ms, Alter?
Was hat der?
Sandstorage, meint er.
Das heißt, er hat noch mal irgendwo
da unten irgendwie, äh,
what the fuck?
Ob das denn Sandstorage ist oder nicht,
hat nix mit der Kiste zu tun, sondern
geht's rein um die Anbindung.
What the fuck?
Dann hat er, dann hat er noch
drei, drei ESXe
nur für Storage.
Warum?
Okay, es ist cool, ich, ich sag nix, ja?
Ich bin der Letzte, der, der, die, die, die
Warum-Frage, warum macht man sowas, beantworten
kann. Ich hab ja auch viel unsinnige Sachen.
A Windows Virtual Machine
and a Windows Storage Spaces.
It's very similar to my, äh, setting up a
Cluster Storage Video. Ähm, but yeah,
so that's,
for the most part, what I use that
Chassis for.
Ich bezweifle, dass es ein Zahn ist, was
er hat, überhaupt, ja? Also, Zahn,
das bedeutet ja im Prinzip nix anderes
wie, du hast noch mal ein extra,
nennen wir es mal Netzwerk, was
dediziert für, äh, Storage verwendet
wird. Was in der Regel nichts anderes
bedeutet als, man hat ein paar
Fiber Channel Karten, Glasfaser,
gedünst dazwischen, und man schließt
eben darüber die einzelnen Server an,
anstatt, dass es über das vorhandene
IP-Netzwerk geht.
Ähm, das ist der ein, das ist der
einzige Unterschied, ja? Sinnvoll daheim
ist es nicht. Mich würde auch ehrlich
gesagt interessieren, ob es wirklich, ob
man da wirklich jetzt irgendwelche
Fiber Channel Sachen hat. Oder ob er
einfach, ähm, over IP oder so macht.
Weil, wenn man es ganz streng nimmt, ist
ja over IP kein Zahn mehr. Zahn bedeutet
ja wirklich ein eigenes Netzwerk oder
eine eigene Infrastruktur, rein fürs
Deutsch, nix anderes. Sonst,
sonst ist es im Prinzip so eine Art
Nass. Ja, man könnte sagen, okay, wenn man
quasi, äh, sowas wie ISCSI oder so, so, so
Raw Devices über IP, dann ist es noch
sowas, äh, das ist Definitionsfrage und
im Prinzip auch egal.
Welchen Mikrotik-Route empfiehlst du?
Wie gesagt, immer den hier. Immer den, den
finde ich top. Preis-Leistungs-Mit, das
ist die beste Kombination, finde ich,
wegen, äh, du kriegst PoE, du kriegst
ordentlich Leistung für daheim und du
brauchst nur 50 Euro oder 55 oder so.
Du hast sogar einen SFP-Port, falls man
den braucht, sollte.
Hier neben, für die ganz, äh, für die
ganz experimentierfreudigen, hier neben
kann man auch noch einen USB-Stick
reinstecken und, äh, Netzwerk-Storage
machen, aber das will man nicht, weil das
voll für den Arsch ist.
Ähm, aber beide haben 48 GB RAM, der
eine am Top ist, äh, zwei, äh, zwei Quad-Cores
und der eine am Boden sind zwei 6-Cores.
Und dann powering all this, I have two
Cyber-Power-Cores.
10.000, äh, ähm, UPS-Backup, Battery-Backups.
Ähm, those are probably gonna need a
period of time.
Der macht's richtig, der hat zwei
USV'en.
Nicht, nicht so blöd wie ich mit einer
USV, die verreckt ist und, ähm, und quasi
das ganze Ding abgeschaltet hat.
If I add anything else to this.
Alright, so now I got the server rack
pulled out from the back.
Was hältst du von den Router-Bots?
Das ist ja im Prinzip genau das gleiche,
was hier auch drin ist, nur halt ohne
Gehäuse.
I can see what I got going on back there.
Let's see how this is all configured.
Also, noch nicht fertig, ne, die, hier sind
auch ganz normale Router-Bots drinne, äh,
nämlich hier in dem Fall ein RBE-9-Dings,
bla, blub, halt schon mit Netzteil-Gehäuse
und allem dabei.
Äh, wie schaltet man den zwei USVs zusammen?
Ich glaube nicht, dass die zusammengeschaltet
sind.
Ich denke mal, die eine USV ist für die
obere, äh, für die oberen Kisten und die
untere ist für das Storage oder so.
So you see the box just easily pulls out
and it just separates from the server,
no problem.
And it's really just a hollow box, there's
nothing in it, it just sits there.
Ah, jetzt sehen wir es mal, okay, okay, also
haben wir hier irgendwo,
ich seh, ist kein Fiber-Channel gedürzt
zwischen,
ich will mal sein Storage sehen, sieht man
sein Storage hier irgendwo, wenn er da rumläuft?
Hold on from the back and let's take a quick look
around how it's all configured.
Ne, man sieht sein Storage nicht.
And it just separates from the server,
no problem, and it's really just a hollow
box, there's nothing in it, it just sits there.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, da ist kein,
da ist keine Fiber-Channel,
da ist kein Fiber-Channel-Geschichten.
Ne.
Ist ganz, ist, ist ganz, ganz klassisch, ja, also.
Übrigens hier, eine Runde Seriell und VGA,
PS2, ich sagte, im Rechenzentrum ist die Zeit
stehen geblieben, was Schnittstellen angeht.
Mittlerweile fangen sie an, mittlerweile gibt's
ein paar Kisten, die haben ein HDMI oder so was dran.
Aber du wirst, fast jeden Server wirst du noch finden
mit VGA.
Ich überleg grad, ob wir es nicht sehen,
sind das redundante Netzteile? Ne, oder?
Ich seh nur einen.
Stecker.
Ne, sind's nicht, oder sind's vielleicht doch?
Also, ich würd, ich würd erst mal auf den ersten
Blick sagen, ja, sind's.
Geht ja auch mit einem Stecker, weil die meisten
zwei Stecker haben.
Weiß nicht, muss, muss man, muss man gucken,
was das für eine Kiste ist.
So, on the top here, I have a Dell PowerConnect
6248, which is a Gig-Bit Layer 3 Switch, and it's
been fantastic, and I tried to cable manage and
color coordinate as much as possible to kind of
keep things clean.
But, obviously, you just end up with a lot of cables
with something like this.
Hat er aber recht ordentlich gemacht.
Red is storage, sand, the, uh, I said, blue is kind of
miscellaneous, and I've just got some random cables
running to the, uh, WiFi router for now.
Um, the black is the Drax, and the yellow is firewall traffic.
Um, but you see, every- Also, 290 für den Hex PoE
ist ganz schön teuer.
Ich hab den irgendwie für, frag mich nicht, 60 Euro
oder so gekauft.
Ja.
Ne, das ist ein anderer.
Hex- Hex PoE braucht man.
Vielleicht kommt man doch nicht ganz, vielleicht kommt man
doch nicht ganz mit 50 Euro aus.
Aber mit 70 Euro bist du dabei.
.
Ja, es ist für ISCSI hat er gesagt.
Ja, ja, hat er gesagt.
.
I-I-I-I Scuzzy, I Scuzzy ist es.
Ja, ich bin ja jemand, der sagt gerne SCSI.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch aussieht.
Seid ihr eher SCSI oder Scuzzy?
Sager.
Für was braucht er denn eine extra Firewall?
Der hat eine extra PFSense, einfach um es zu haben.
Glaube ich.
Na gut.
Ist aber ein schönes Setup, was er hat.
Also es ist wirklich auch
recht ordentlich gemacht.
Da darf ich ja eh nichts sagen.
Meins sieht da aus wie Sau.
Aber halt auch wieder maßlos
Oversized für irgendwie Heim-Heim-Geschichten.
So ist es halt.
So, was gucken wir denn jetzt?
Patchpanel gucken wir uns an.
Wir gucken uns jetzt
Wie Amazon seine Konkurrenz
zerstört, gucken wir uns an.
Mal schauen.
Debated.
Bevor wir das Video gucken,
muss ich da mal ganz kurz meinen Senf dazu geben.
Ich glaube, dass oftmals
die Konkurrenz sich selber zerstört.
Ich weiß nicht nur, was das Video geht.
Also es kann auch sein, dass es in eine ganz andere Richtung geht.
Also gerade
die Läden, die es früher in den Städten gegeben hat,
wo die Leute hingegangen sind,
die sind halt immer ganz extrem am Meckern.
So nach dem Motto, die Leute, die kaufen bei uns nichts mehr.
Die kaufen bei Amazon.
Die Sache ist halt die, wenn die Leute,
wenn die Läden vor Ort absolut keinen
Mehrwert bieten irgendwie,
dann ist halt klar,
dass ich es bei Amazon bestelle.
Und ich kaufe auch nicht gerade bei Amazon ein,
weil er der billigste ist.
Ich kaufe bei Amazon ein,
weil er der bequemste ist.
Meistens, meistens zumindest der bequemste ist.
Wir können uns das Video gleich angucken.
Also aber alles, was ich bis jetzt gesagt habe,
hat mit Amazon an sich und den lokalen Läden relativ wenig zu tun.
Für mich als Kunde ist Amazon relativ angenehm.
Das ist der Grund, warum ich persönlich so viel bei Amazon bestelle.
Du kannst Sachen easy zurückschicken.
Du kriegst fix und fertig QR-Code zum Einscannen und alles.
Du kriegst Austauschgeräte,
bevor du die alten Geräte zurückschicken musst.
Ansonsten ist der Versand schnell.
Der Versand meistens umsonst.
Es geht allgemein sehr zackig.
Die haben sogar bei uns in der Gegend jetzt Same-Day-Delivery und sowas.
Also da kannst du echt nichts sagen.
Amazon an sich, dann läuft es einfach ziemlich gut.
Amazon hat mehr oder weniger alles, was man braucht.
Ja, also auch Elektronik Sachen, wenn ich schnell,
also wenn ich sie billig haben will,
bestelle ich sie aus China oder halt aus bei Banggood.
Aus irgendeinem Lager aus UK oder sonst wo.
Da geht es ein bisschen schneller.
Wenn ich es halt wirklich schnell brauche, dann bestelle ich es bei Amazon.
So und die Läden, die es lokal gibt bei uns.
Da gibt es auch ein paar Elektronik-Läden.
Das sind Läden, die erzählen, ja kauft keiner mehr ein bei uns.
Aber ich habe mit diesen Läden nur negative Erfahrungen gemacht.
Wenn was kaputt geht, Riesenakt.
Wenn irgendwie was, Beratung für den Arsch und alles.
Also ich habe mit.
Ich habe.
Ich habe seltenst einen Mehrwert erlebt durch lokale Läden.
So und dann ist doch die Frage, wenn ich mich selbst darum kümmern muss
und mir eh selbst Gedanken machen muss, was ich genau brauche
und wie ich das benutze und was ich damit mache.
Warum soll ich zu einem lokalen Laden gehen,
wo ich mir dann auch noch mich mit irgendeinem ungelauten,
genervten Verkäufer irgendwie auseinandersetzen muss?
Kann mich noch dran erinnern, wo ich, wo ich noch jünger war.
Da habe ich mal für damals für DVB-T.
Das war so eines der letzten Sachen, die ich jemals versucht habe,
das ist schon ewig her.
Im Laden zu kaufen, wo ich mir gedacht habe, wir könnten mich alle mal.
Habe ich damals versucht, für als DVB-T angefangen hat
und ich hatte damals kein Kabelanschluss und was haben?
Ich überlege gerade, was wir damals über Fernsehempfang haben.
Keine Ahnung.
Da habe ich mir okay, probierst mal DVB-T aus.
Und da wollte ich mir eine Antenne kaufen.
Da habe ich gesagt okay, weißt du was?
Fährst in so einen kleinen Elektronikladen.
Und kaufst dir da eine Antenne
und da können die dir auch gleich erzählen, welche da für DVB-T gut geeignet ist.
Die haben wir letztendlich.
Das war zum damaligen Zeitpunkt hatte ich keine Ahnung von dem Thema.
Die allerletzten, den allerletzten Scheiß verkauft, der nicht funktioniert hat,
wo das Ganze am Endeffekt dann auch Aussätze hatte, weil DVB-T,
sobald was digital übertragen wird, ist es halt nicht so wie bei Analog,
dass es dann anfängt zu rauschen, sondern man hat halt entweder
Kompressions Artefakte, wenn was nicht richtig ankommt,
oder aber schlicht und klar fehlende Frames und es ruckelt.
Also ruckeln, ruckeln ist das Rauschen des Digitalen quasi.
Oh, das klang jetzt.
Das klang jetzt echt.
Big Brain philosophisch, oder?
Ruckeln ist das Rauschen des Digitalen.
Ja, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine wahrscheinlich.
Also früher hast du, wenn es analoges Signal war, Fernseh sonst wie,
hat es halt gerauscht, also gerauscht in Form von gegrisselt im Bild oder bei Audio gerauscht.
Und heute ist es halt so, wenn die Sachen digital übertragen werden,
was auch immer es ist, MPEG-2, H.264, was auch immer,
hast du entweder Kompressions, also irgendwelche Artefakte
oder schlicht und ergreifend fehlende Bilder und es ruckelt.
Und das ist halt bei DVB-T auch gewesen.
Das hat halt überhaupt nicht funktioniert.
Und dann habe ich im Internet nachgeguckt und habe halt gesagt,
okay, für meine Lage ist halt diese Sorte von Antenne nicht gut.
Da bin ich wieder hin, habe die Antenne angesehen,
das funktioniert überhaupt nicht.
Und ich habe im Internet mal nachgeguckt, für meine Lage wäre eine andere Antenne besser.
Und da hat die Verkäuferin wirklich gemeint,
ja, ja, die Leute gucken immer im Internet nach und irgendwie so nach dem Motto,
ja, ja, die Leute gucken immer im Internet nach, aber im Internet steht auch viel Mist.
Da habe ich mir gesagt, ja, Moment, aber die Antenne, die sie mir verkauft haben,
funktioniert auch nicht.
Ja, ich habe jetzt mal nachgeguckt, ich habe die Antenne zurückgegeben
und bin nie wieder in Offline-Läden für sowas reingegangen.
Der einzige Offline-Laden, in den ich noch gehe, ist der Konrad auf der Zeil für Elektronik-Kram,
wenn ich da mal wirklich schnell Elektronik-Kram brauche,
weil die haben ein riesen Sortiment an Elektronik-Kram
und dort gehst du einfach hin, kriegst deinen Scheiß und kannst wieder heimgehen.
Und das ist meiner Ansicht nach das Problem,
von vielen Offline-Läden, weil sie keinerlei Mehrwert bieten gegenüber,
ich muss selbst im Internet gucken und bestelle im Internet.
Es ist einfach nur stressiger.
Konrad ist nur sehr teuer, das stimmt, dafür kriegst du die Sachen am gleichen Tag
oder zur gleichen Stunde, wenn du da bist.
So, und ich habe die letzten Jahre nur alles online, wirklich alles.
Sogar den Trockner und die Waschmaschine habe ich online bestellt, alles.
Also die einzigen Sachen, die ich nicht online bestelle, sind Lebensmittel.
Ich gehe nicht mehr in Geschäfte.
Außer vielleicht zum Konrad für Elektronik-Kram, wenn es wirklich schnell gehen muss.
Ich gehe in keine Geschäfte mehr und da ist nicht unbedingt Amazon dran schuld,
weil sie die kleinen Läden irgendwie fertig gemacht hätten,
sondern da sind zum größten Teil die kleinen Läden,
in denen ich bisher gewesen bin, selbst dran schuld, dass ich da nicht mehr hingehe.
Und Amazon trägt insofern dazu bei, weil es bei Amazon angenehm ist zu bestellen,
weil es eine große Auswahl gibt und weil es schnell geht.
Dass Amazon nicht der Billigste ist,
das ist, glaube ich, auch mittlerweile allen klar.
Amazon kostet meistens sogar einen Ticken mehr, wenn man jetzt, also gut,
wenn man mal die China-Geschichten außen vor lässt.
Die China-Geschichten sind eh eigentlich viel billiger, als es sein kann.
Wenn ich mir überlege, ich kann aus China irgendwelche Microcontroller-Geschichten bestellen oder USB.
Hier, ich habe einen 50er-Pack USB-Kabel bestellt.
USB, USB-C, USB, Micro-USB.
Also in einem.
Das ist quasi ein USB-Kabel mit einem Stecker für Micro-USB und einem Stecker für USB-C.
Also man kann natürlich nur eins davon verwenden.
So, 50er-Pack USB-Kabel bestellt für, glaube ich, 45 Euro inklusive Versand aus China.
Also sprich, ich habe weniger, also ich habe, keine Ahnung, 90 Cent oder 95 Cent oder so bezahlt
pro USB, zwei Meter USB-Kabel, USB-C, Micro-USB.
Das ist halt aus China.
Das ist wirklich billig.
Erst von Amazon.
Fuck.
Ja, und das ist eigentlich viel billiger, als es irgendwie sein dürfte.
Ich habe dafür weniger bezahlt.
Also der Versand aus China ist billiger gewesen, als Deutschland nach Deutschland.
Das mal außen vor ist trotzdem Amazon bei den meisten Sachen nicht der günstigste.
Aber ich finde bei den meisten Sachen eben der angenehmste.
So, und jetzt gucken wir uns mal, das war mein Senf dazu.
Und jetzt gucken wir uns mal an, was er dazu zu sagen hat.
Zu Bärenkrallen fürs Grillen.
Naja, Amazon verkauft Mittagsessen.
Mittlerweile auch auf Amazon findet man fast alles.
Er gehört übrigens zu den coolen Leuten.
Er sagt Amazon.
Von Büchern über Möbel über Videospiele bis hin zu Bärenkrallen fürs Grillen.
Naja.
Also ich frage mich gerade, wofür man die braucht.
Zum Fleisch, zu so Pullpork auseinander pullen oder wie?
Man kann einfach ein paar Gabeln nehmen oder einfach Bärenkrallen.
Bärenkrallen, easy.
Cool aus.
Kannst du nochmal wiederholen, wo die Kabel bestellt werden?
AliExpress.
Wo habe ich die bestellt?
Wenn du willst, können wir nachher nochmal gucken, ob ich die wiederfinde.
Aber die gibt es nicht mehr.
Die habe ich vor einem Jahr bestellt oder so.
Aber wir können bei AliExpress gleich nochmal gucken.
50er Pack USB-Kabel.
Oder bei Banggood.
Kannst du auch gucken.
Banggood ist keine Pornseite.
Hört sich so an, aber Banggood ist ein China-Shop.
Also du kriegst halt viel für deinen, für deinen, also für den, für den Backbang irgendwie.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich verstehe den Namen.
Ich verstehe die Benamung von Banggood auch nicht so genau.
Aber sie heißt dann einfach Banggood.
Banggood, AliExpress, Gearbest und, ähm, Vierten im Bunde habe ich vergessen.
Es gibt noch ein paar mehr, aber das waren so die größten.
Wie gibt es denn da noch?
Wer ist denn noch so?
Banggood, AliExpress, Gearbest und es gibt auch noch einen Vierten.
Nicht Wish.
Kommt mir nicht mit Wish an.
Die meine ich nicht.
China-Shops.
Banggood, Gearbest, AliExpress, Alibaba ist, ist ja für, genau, ich kaufe 50.000 Stück.
Wie hieß der denn?
Der eine, AliExpress, Banggood, Gearbest, wie, wie heißt der andere im, im Bunde?
Die H-Gate, meine ich.
Die H-Gate.
Die, die, die gibt es auch noch.
Da habe ich aber noch nie was bestellt.
Die, die, die ploppen aber, die H-Gate, meine ich, genau.
Die ploppen aber auch öfters mal auf.
Okay, wir gucken jetzt erst mal das Video.
Was er da zu sagen hat.
Dann, und dann kann ich noch mal auf, auf AliExpress gucken, ob wir noch mal 50 USB-Kabel finden.
Für unter 1 Euro das Stück.
Amazon verkauft mittlerweile auch eigene Produkte.
Diese Eigenmarken kennen aber die wenigsten.
Amazon Basics, ja.
Hundefutter von VAG, Amazon.
Was?
Es gibt Amazon Hundefutter, ich kenne nur Amazon Basics.
VAG.
Kinderleggings von Spotted Zebra, Amazon.
Samtstühle von Rivet, Amazon.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich muss das passende Emote kurz raussuchen.
Kinderleggings von Spotted Zebra, Amazon.
Samtstühle von Rivet.
Den, den, den, den brauche ich sonst nie, das Emote.
Es ist, hat sich jetzt mal angeboten wieder.
Amazon.
Dem Konzern gehören inzwischen unzählige solcher Marken mit hunderttausenden Produkten.
Bis 2022 wird Amazon voraussichtlich 31 Milliarden Dollar Umsatz mit seinen Eigenmarken machen.
Der Konzern wird langsam zu einem der größten Anbieter auf seiner eigenen Plattform.
Doch hinter den Produkten von Amazon verbirgt sich eine skrupellose, vielleicht sogar illegale Sprache.
Kannst du welche für 20 bis 30 Euro empfehlen, was denn?
Es geht um manipulative Werbung.
Achso, by the way, weil jemand gefragt hat gerade.
Nein, ich habe keinen Zoll bezahlt.
Weil wenn es die AliExpress Anbieter richtig machen, ist es auch ordentlich, ähm, ausgewiesen alles.
Gestohlene Ideen und ultimativ auch um die Frage, wird Amazon zu mächtig?
Big Brain Intro.
Es ist 2016.
Yuri Petriv und Oleg Maslaku haben eine geniale Idee für ein Produkt.
Die Namen, die sind ja mal sowas von gekommret.
Mit dem sogenannten Car-Trunk-Organizer kann man endlich seinen Kofferraum aufräumen und organisiert halten.
Die beiden gründen eine Firma in Brooklyn und bieten ihr Produkt für rund 25 Dollar auf Amazon an.
Es ist wahnsinnig erfolgreich.
Boah.
Ordentlich.
30.000 Mal verkauft.
Doch wenige Jahre später.
Boah, der Anteil ist ja krass.
Also, wenn das aus dem gleichen Zeitraum ist.
7.000 Bewertungen für 33 Verkauf-
Das ist extrem viel.
Die meisten Leute bewerten ja nicht.
Überraschung.
Amazon bringt unter dem Namen seiner Eigenmarke Amazon Basics ein zum Verwechseln ähnliches Produkt auf den Markt.
Ja, okay, das ist, das ist kacke sowas.
Aussehen, Material, Preis, Maße, alles fast genau gleich.
Das Produkt ist ebenfalls ein Erfolg.
Hatte Amazon hier einfach nur den richtigen Riecher?
Oder hat der Konzern Petriff und Maslaku vielleicht ausspioniert und ganz dreist ihre Idee geklaut?
Dem Wall Street Journal liegt ein internes Dokument vor.
Amazon-Mitarbeiter haben die Verkaufszahlen, die Kundendaten und die Kosten der beiden Männer bis ins kleinste Detail studiert.
Alles vertrauliche Informationen ihres Accounts, den Amazon natürlich einsehen kann.
In den USA ist Amazon gigantisch.
Auch in Deutschland ist Amazon fast dreimal so groß wie der zweitgrößte Online-Hit der Otto-
Alter, die gibt's doch...
Du hörst Zalando nicht jetzt auch? Amazon oder irgendwie...
Zalando wurde doch verkauft, oder?
Oder hab ich das falsch in Erinnerung?
Wurde nicht verkauft?
Vielleicht bring ich's auch durcheinander, kann auch sein.
Ähm...
Allerdings, lustigerweise ist das nix gegen AliExpress, beziehungsweise gegen Alibaba.
Die Chinesen gehen da noch mehr ab.
Das Unternehmen wird immer größer.
Neben seinem Marktplatz macht Amazon Milliardengeschäfte mit seinen Cloud-Diensten.
Amazon gehört außerdem eine der größten Supermarktketten in den USA, der Streaming-Dienst Prime Video und das Streaming-Portal Twitch.
Amazon-CEO Jeff Bezos steht jetzt sogar kurz davor, Raketen ins All zu schießen.
Amazon ist ein Megakonglomerat und nutzt seine Übermacht und Omnipräsenz scheinbar schadlos aus.
Die beiden Jungs aus Brooklyn sind nämlich vermutlich kein Einzelfall.
Amazon besitzt wertvolle Daten von Millionen von Verkäufern.
Von über 1.000 Verkäufern auf Amazon gab mehr als die Hälfte an, dass Amazon ein fast identisches Produkt zu ihrem anbietet.
Der Konzern scheint intern Leute darauf anzusetzen, Bestseller auf der Plattform aufs Genaueste zu analysieren, um sie hinterher einfach zu kopieren.
20 Amazon-Mitarbeiter haben dem Wall Street Journal bestätigt, dass so ein Vorgehen nicht die Ausnahme, sondern die Regel sei.
Auch Jeff Bezos kann das nicht ausschließen.
Wir haben eine Vorgehensweise gegen das,
dass Verkäufer spezifische Daten verwendet werden.
Das ist ja Rausreden hoch 10.
Da kann ich einfach sagen, so nach dem Motto, nein, das machen wir nicht, das ist verboten.
Die sagen, ja, ich habe eine Policy erlassen, die da und da Sachen untersagt.
Ich meine, letztendlich, er ist der Chef.
Wenn das nicht gemacht werden soll, dann muss er dafür sorgen, dass das nicht gemacht werden soll.
... unser privates Label-Business.
Aber ich kann dir nicht garantieren,
dass diese Policy nie verletzt wurde.
Ja, ja.
Doch das ist noch lange nicht alles.
Amazon kann seine Produkte auf der eigenen Plattform so hart pushen, wie es will.
Und tut es auch.
Amazons Hundefutter kriegt den Ehrenplatz ganz oben links.
Genauso Amazons Kinder-Leggings.
Und Amazons Samtstühle...
Ah ja, okay, verstehe.
Amazons Batterien werden sogar als Amazons Choice gekennzeichnet.
Das ist so, als würde man einen Bäcker fragen, wo es die besten Brötchen der Stadt gibt.
Andere Händler geben für solche Rankings monatlich hunderttausende Dollar aus.
So vertreibt Amazon die Konkurrenz von den besten Plätzen im eigenen Haus.
Amazon hat seine eigenen Produkte übrigens auch jahrelang nicht als Eigenprodukte gekennzeichnet.
Muss man das?
Ist das Pflicht?
Ich meine, Lidl nennt ja auch nicht ihre Produkte Lidl.
Sondern die heißt...
Stimmt, ich komme echt ab und zu mal an das Mikrofon.
Wenn ich mal in den Bart greife, muss ich mal gucken, dass ich das anders platziere.
Das ist wirklich doof.
Lidl nennt das Zeug ja auch nicht Lidl, sondern haben da irgendwelche Eigenmarkennamen, die nicht unbedingt auf Lidl schließen lassen.
Und Unmengen an Daten.
Dagegen haben zwei Jungs aus Brooklyn auf lange Sicht absolut keine Chance.
Diese Dominanz zerstört den fairen Wettbewerb und verhindert Innovation.
Wenn Amazon Ideen klaut und nur die eigenen Produkte bewirbt, verlieren die anderen Verkäufer die Motivation.
Es werden keine neuen Produkte entwickelt und es wird weniger erfunden.
Darunter leiden auch die Kunden.
Das stimmt, das klingt logisch, ja.
Wenn wir jetzt nichts unternehmen gegen die große Marktmacht von Amazon...
Das ist Viktor Meyer-Schönberger, Professor für Internet Governance and Regulation an der Oxford Universität.
Dann hat in 20 Jahren Amazon die Größe der Tyrell Corporation im Film Blade Runner erreicht.
Eine Unternehmung, die praktisch die gesamte Welt beherrscht.
Und von der Wiege bis zur Bahre alle Dienstleistungen abdeckt.
Das wäre die große, schlimme Dystopie.
Ordentliche Sennheiser-Headset hat er.
... der uns bevorstehen würde.
Immer wieder wird gefordert, dass Amazon und andere Tech-Giganten zerschlagen werden sollten.
Dann würden nicht mehr nur ein paar wenige Konzerne so gut wie alles beherrschen, was online angeboten wird.
Facebook müsste dann zum Beispiel WhatsApp und Instagram wieder verkaufen.
Amazon müsste sich von seinen Eigenmarken trennen.
Die EU-Kommission ermittelt tatsächlich bereits, ob Amazon mit seinen Eigenprodukten gegen das Kartellrecht verstößt.
Aber würde das wirklich für mehr Wettbewerb und Innovation sorgen?
Was Amazon, Google und Facebook so unfassbar mächtig macht, sind Daten.
Exklusive, wertvolle Daten, die sonst niemand hat.
Laut Professor Meyer-Schönberger würde eine Zerschlagung deshalb nicht viel bringen.
Damit würde man nur das Symptom bekämpfen, aber nicht die Ursache.
Es wäre deutlich sinnvoller, wenn jeder Zugang zu diesen wertvollen Daten hätte.
Dabei geht es nicht um hochsensible, personenbezogene Daten.
Das wollen die auf keinen Fall.
Es geht um zusammengefasste Marktdaten, zum Beispiel zum Kaufverhalten von Kunden.
Wenn alle die gleichen Informationen haben, sind die Spielregeln fair.
Der kleine Händler kann dann bessere Entscheidungen treffen.
Er weiß genau, worauf die Kunden achten und was sie an Produkten wertschätzen.
Und Amazon müsste dann ebenfalls mit Service und Qualität überzeugen und nicht durch reine Größe.
Amazon kann zwei Jungs in Brooklyn einfach ihre Idee klauen und niemand scheint das verhindern zu können.
Das ist nicht nur gruselig, sondern ein Symptom eines größeren Problems.
Amazon wird immer und immer größer, nicht nur in Deutschland, sondern global.
Amazon bietet nicht mehr nur eine Plattform.
Der Konzern ist längst selbst als Verkäufer auf der eigenen Seite unterwegs und bewirbt seine Produkte aggressiv.
Vertrauliche Daten von anderen Anbietern werden eingesehen, um eigene Kopien zu launchen.
Die Konkurrenz wird schonungslos ausgemerzt.
Daten sind Macht und einige wenige Unternehmen haben unfassbar viel davon.
Die Musik dabei...
Daten zu demokratisieren ist vielleicht unkonventionell, aber eventuell eine mögliche Lösung.
Sonst wird Amazon vielleicht wirklich unsere Tyrell Corporation.
Cheers.
Ja, gutes Video.
Wir hoffen wie immer, dass euch dieses Video gefallen hat.
Sibaro schreibt, mir kommt gerade die Idee Max-Choice für Amazon-Produkte.
Die Idee ist eigentlich gar nicht übel, allerdings ist es sehr Nischen-Zeug, was ich halt oft kaufe.
Irgendwelche Elektronik-Kram und sonst was.
Wobei, gar nicht verkehrt vielleicht, wenn man sehen kann, was ich schon ausprobiert habe und was halt kaputt gegangen ist und was halt gut funktioniert.
Welche Tastatur kannst du empfehlen?
Zum Spielen oder für Arbeiten?
Also, oder Allround und Arbeiten oder rein zum Spielen?
Also, Allround und Arbeiten, das...
Wieder?
Poggers?
Ich kann dir nur die zeigen, die ich ausprobiert habe.
Also, es kann sein, dass da schon Nachfolgeprodukte von gibt.
Aber nicht die, die mit Numplog.
Die mit Numplog, wohlgemerkt.
Also, nicht die.
Also, die gibt es auch noch mit Numplog.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die im Bild überhaupt...
Ja, die da.
Ne, Moment.
Numplog?
Also, die mit Numplog.
So, die da.
Top.
Was kann die denn so Tolles?
Auf der kann man gut schreiben.
Das reicht eigentlich.
Du kannst ein bisschen Makro-Gedöns mit so einem Knopf hinten dran machen und so.
Aber ganz ehrlich, eigentlich kann man auf der nur gut schreiben.
Wow.
What the fuck.
Genau.
Die.
Die da.
Und die habe ich auf der Arbeit seit...
2 Jahren oder so.
Wirklich top.
Ich habe so einen Tick.
Ich schlage immer auf die Numplog-Taste.
Also, ihr habt es vielleicht schon gemerkt, wenn ich im Terminal irgendwas tippe.
So, keine Ahnung.
Da gucke ich mir den Befehl nochmal an, bevor ich ihn ausführe.
Und dann, bam, haue ich so auf die Enter-Taste vom Numplog.
Zum Abschicken.
Und deswegen habe ich mir ein paar Gummiringe gekauft.
Um die unter die Tasten zu machen, auf die ich am festesten drauf haue.
Um meine Kollegen auf der Arbeit nicht gar so sehr zu nerven.
Schau mal die Bewertung.
Eine Bewertung.
Bist du das?
Haha, guck mal wer da ist.
Lol.
Der cute Mod himself.
Also, Sibaro ist begeistert von der Tastatur, wie es aussieht.
Die ist aber wirklich gut.
Wie gesagt, die habe ich auch schon seit einer ganzen Weile auf der Arbeit.
So, und zum...
Hier daheim habe ich jetzt mittlerweile...
Und das ist der einzige Grund, warum ich die nicht daheim habe.
Ist...
Zumindest zu 90% der Grund, warum ich die nicht daheim habe.
Auch ist, weil ich ein bisschen Makro-Gedöns mit der Logitech Software machen will.
So, und daheim habe ich eine G...
Tja, was habe ich denn für eine Tastatur überhaupt?
Eine G?
Tja, äh...
Wo steht denn das?
Äh...
Ich guck gerade hinten drauf.
Seriennummer habe ich...
G513.
Habe ich daheim.
Die da habe ich daheim.
Die ist auch okay.
Einzige, was an der richtig dumm ist,
dass die Tastatur und die Handballenablage
nicht zusammen sind.
Also, die rutscht jetzt nicht laufend weg,
aber ich muss schon alle...
Keine Ahnung, einmal in der Stunde so kurz dran schieben,
dass das wieder exakt gerade ist.
Aber ansonsten ist die auch okay.
Wobei ich die Ducky One Skyline klar empfehlen würde,
wenn man eine Allround-Tastatur braucht
und hauptsächlich zum Tippen und Arbeiten.
Dann ist die Ducky One Skyline, finde ich,
mit die beste Tastatur.
Ich mache auch fast alles über NumBlock.
Aber ich sehe, das ist schwierig im Chat.
Manche sagen, NumBlock braucht man nicht.
Manche sagen, NumBlock beste.
Okay, das taugt nichts.
Nennt mich da zu pessimistisch, ja.
Aber...
Ich glaube nicht, dass das was taugt.
Das hauptsächliche Problem an solchen...
An solchen Telefonen ist,
dass es keine Hersteller gibt,
die sie supporten.
Also sprich,
99% der Apps gibt es dafür nicht.
Aber schauen wir uns das mal an.
Big...
Excellent Musik, ja.
Okay, gucken wir uns...
Habe ich im Chat was übersehen?
Ich scrolle mal kurz...
Ich scrolle mal kurz durch.
Der Tobias C4G hat geschrieben,
dass man bei diesem Amazon Fake Corp ja erkennt,
dass es schon viel schlechter ist,
als es in der Quali ist.
Ja, kann sein.
Allerdings glaube ich,
ist es den meisten Leuten egal.
Ich habe eh den Eindruck,
dass viele Leute kein gutes Gefühl
für irgendwie Qualität haben.
Ich glaube, die meisten Leute
würden den Unterschied nicht merken
zwischen einem...
Ich sage jetzt einfach mal Aldi
Schraubendreher-Set
oder irgendwie einem...
Keine Ahnung, ist jetzt egal,
was hast du denn da sonst noch?
Was hast du denn da sonst noch?
HZ, Stahlwille,
was auch immer, ist es eigentlich egal.
Also, die meisten Leute würden das nicht...
HZ, genau.
Vihar gibt es auch noch, ja.
Die meisten Leute würden den Unterschied nicht merken.
Die haben da kein Gefühl für.
Die regen sich dann zwar auf,
wenn es kaputt geht oder nicht richtig funktioniert,
aber auf die Idee kommen,
dass es an ihrem billigen Einkauf liegt,
kommen die meisten Leute nicht drauf.
Was arbeitest du?
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen...
Wie ist das?
Ausrufezeichen Arbeit, Ausrufezeichen Job?
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wo ich das...
Wir haben da ein Kommando für.
Ausrufezeichen Arbeit, ja.
Spiel jetzt das Video ab.
Hier, Trigard.
Schon am Zittern.
Laut genug?
Prozentschutz für alle
stccsart charakteristischen Tausend punkte
Frau
wird
ein
Was für ein bescheuerter Name.
Postmarked OS.
Gute Frage, Warty.
Gute Frage.
Ich sage BTRFS.
BTRFS.
Es gibt Leute, die sagen BetaFS.
Ich habe auch schon ButterFS gehört.
Ja, und was auch immer.
BTRFS gibt es verschiedenste Aussprache.
Ich bin für BTRFS.
High Quality AliExpress USB Kabel.
Ist das gebogen?
Hat das Dellen?
Oder ist es einfach nur der Handabdruck von ihm?
Das sieht ein bisschen so aus, als hat das eine Delle.
Täuscht nur, okay.
Fett.
Naja, ganz ehrlich, im Vergleich zu dem...
Ich habe jetzt seit einer Weile hier ein iPhone XS, XR, X...
Was ist das Kleine?
XS, glaube ich.
Das ist auch fett.
Vor allem mit einer Hülle drum ist das huge fett.
Sick.
So sick wie May, ja.
So yeah, I've actually been really excited about getting my hands on this device.
I've personally been wanting to test a Linux-powered smartphone for a long time.
And this one definitely makes it easier and more accessible for everybody to get their hands on it.
It's open source, so we can freely flash different operating systems of this,
just like we do with single-board computers.
But now, we have a phone for that.
Ja, super.
Ja, kann ich jetzt 85 Linux-Distros drauf flashen, wovon keine richtig funktioniert, wofür es keine ordentliche Apps gibt.
Excellent.
So this one here came pre-installed with PostMarket OS.
They're also releasing a Manjaro version, but we can grab that operating system and throw it on this...
Stimmt, Android, ja, bei Android kann man wahrscheinlich nicht drauf machen.
Und dann ist die Version wahrscheinlich so schlecht supported, dass man nicht mal Videos abspielt.
In this video, we're gonna be taking a look at PostMarket OS.
Upon first boot, we do have a little bit of setup we need to do, just like any other new device.
I have to throw in a PIN-Code, so I'm gonna go ahead and do that.
It's also gonna ask me if I wanna enable SSH.
Okay.
I do wanna enable that, so I can access it from a different computer.
Excellent. Kannst du gleich per SSH auf dein Smartphone connecten.
And finally, it's gonna give me the option to fully encrypt the storage on the PinePhone, and that's a big...
Äh, JollyJoker, vier Monate. Dankeschön. Excellent subscription. Huge. Moment hier.
Big Brain, Big Brain.
...plus to running Linux on a device like this.
And once we're done with that, it's gonna start the PostMarket OS.
Das sieht irgendwie... Ich weiß, es hört sich jetzt übelst negativ an, ja, und ich denke, dass da wirklich viele clevere Leute auch mit dabei gewesen sind.
Ich will das jetzt nicht zu schlecht reden, aber allein schon, wie das hier ausschaut, sieht irgendwie aus wie...
Wir haben uns hingesetzt und, äh, keine Ahnung, mit Frontpage eine Webseite zusammengewurstet und ein Logo gebaut, äh.
Sieht aus wie ein Schulpro... Ja, genau das. Ja, genau. Genau das.
Genau das. Genau so sieht's aus.
...Installation. You can actually flash this over USB Type-C, or you can flash it using an SD-Card if you ever need to reinstall an operating system.
So, taking a look at the specs, this is not high-end by any means. For the CPU, we have the all-winner A64.
Das ist aber nicht schlecht.
...Cortex A53 CPU, running at 1.2 GHz. The GPU is the Mali 400 MP2. As for RAM, they offer two variants...
Das ist...
...two Giga...
Ist das nicht...
...relativ ähnlich zu dem, was in dem Raspberry Pi drin ist, in dem neuen?
In dem Vierer?
Das ist nicht ziemlich ähnlich?
...or three, it's using LPDDR3 in both. We have another option for storage, 16 GB, up to 32, and the display is a 5.95 LCD at 1440x720.
We do have built-in Wi-Fi and Bluetooth 4.0, but unfortunately the Wi-Fi chip in here is only an 802.11b G&N chip, single-band, 2.4 GHz.
So we can't pick up...
...that 5 GHz network.
I am by no means a professional...
Was? Wie? Kein 5G?
Äh, kein 5G.
Ah, kein 5 GHz, äh, WLAN?
Habe ich das richtig gehört?
...2.4 GHz, so we can't pick up that 5 GHz network.
I am by no means a professional on-cellular bands, but on their wiki they do have their LTE, WCDMA, and GSM bands listed.
Ob die jetzt Bluetooth 5 haben, würde mich jetzt persönlich nicht so jucken.
Aber kein, äh, kein 5 GHz WLAN, und...
...aber kein, äh, kein 5 GHz WLAN, und...
Now I have read in a few posts that your best bet for using this in the US would be on Verizon or Sprint, because it's missing some important bands for AT&T and T-Mobile.
Like I mentioned, I'm not a professional on this, I actually don't know much about it.
Hier kannst du wahrscheinlich gar nicht richtig verwenden.
...connected to a network to begin with, but all of the bands are listed here on their wiki, and I'll leave a link in the description.
Alright, so here we are, I've got everything set up, and one of the main things I'm worried about...
Das sieht aus wie ein ganz normaler Gnome-Launcher gerade.
...devices.
...mainly performance, and I know this is a development device, this is not made for the end-consumer, but I'm still really worried about it, because we're using that very low-end, all-winner-C...
Wow.
...performance, and I know this is a development device, this is not made for the end-consumer, but I'm still really worried about it, because...
Das kann doch nicht in der Ernst sein!
Das...
Das ist doch der Witz.
Das wäre ja mit JavaScript im Browser schneller.
...devices, mainly performance, and I know this is a development device, this is not made for the end-consumer, but I'm still really worried about it, because we're using that very low-end, all-winner-CPU at 1.2 Gigahertz.
Das dauert ja drei Stunden, bis das auf ist!
Das ist ein ganz normaler Gnome-GTK-Oberflug, das dauert ja ewig!
...the device, and about, should give us a little bit of information...
...two gigs of RAM...
Das steht normal als Gnome, ist das.
...Gnome-Desktop, and we'll check for...
What the fuck?
...we've got one update here for Firefox.
Warum bringen die das überhaupt raus?
I'll go ahead and update it.
So far, it is feeling a little bit sluggish, and I kind of expected this going into it.
We're using a very early build of post-market OS here, on a low-end, all-winner-Chipset.
The screen actually looks really...
Das ist ein Raspberry Pi, schneller!
...good, it's not a super high-end...
Viel schneller!
...high-end AMOLED-Display, like Samsung uses, but it's an IPS at 1440x720, it'll definitely get you by.
Now these phones are going for $150, all the way up to $200...
Guck mal, die Dings gehen halt immer zu!
...depending on the package that you choose. They have kind of a little starter pack that comes with a few things.
And one of the things that I really actually like about this device is the choice and...
Boah, wie es ruckelt! Habt ihr gesehen, wie es ruckelt beim Scrollen?
Guckt euch mal an, wie das ruckelt!
...operating systems.
Moment, Moment.
...200, depending on the package that you choose. They have kind of a little starter pack that comes with a few things.
And one of the things that I really actually like about this device...
Guck mal! Wie es ruckelt! ...is the choice and operating systems. Guck mal, wie es ruckelt!
...operating systems.
There is a ton available right now for the Pine Phone, and definitely keep an eye on the channel, because I will be testing a couple...
Ja, das stimmt, es ist günstig, aber was hast du davon, wenn es absolut unbenutzbar ist? ...in a dedicated video.
...but I do want to personally...
Da hole ich mir lieber, also für 150 Dollar, dann würde ich mir irgendein Xiaomi China Android Phone holen oder so, low-end, das wird gar nicht besser läuft als das.
...and a little time with PostMarket OS, because this is what the phone shipped with.
So I'll leave this on here for about a week.
I'll get used to it, and if my Google Fi SIM-Card works on this, I'll try to daily drive this for a few days at least.
Oh, viel Spaß.
But one thing I did want to try out real quick was the built-in store.
Mich würde mal interessieren, kann der mal YouTube aufmachen?
Ich glaube, dann können wir eine Runde kecken.
...download different applications.
You can also do it through terminal, but since we have the store installed, let's see how it looks.
I think it's very limited right now, but we should be able to get GIMP, and I just saw it pop up.
GIMP auf dem Smartphone? Oh Gott.
We'll try this. Oh Gott. Ich, ich ahme.
Ich ahme, dass es schlimm ist.
...and see how it works.
Not sure how it's gonna perform on this small 5-point-inch screen, but let's see if it even installs.
This is one of the best open-source image-editing applications that you can use on Linux or even Windows.
And it looks like it's installing. I'll just give it a second to make sure everything went okay.
And I think it should be on our desktop or our app.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Mein GIMP ist so schon eklig. Und jetzt auf...
...starts up pretty quickly, but as I suspected, this is definitely not optimal.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich erlebe in diesem Fall wirklich keinerlei Prüfungen, denn das
artet.
Ich finde wirklich ja die Be amendierung zu groß.
Moment, faster? Das ist ja, mein Fire HD ist schneller. Mein 50 Euro Fire HD Amazon Tablet ist schneller.
Das ist echt huge.
Oh, ist das schlecht. Ist das schlecht, Alter. Landscape geht das gar nicht.
Ich bin gerade sehr spät, hochkant.
Und es ruckelt. Es ruckelt auch noch.
Ja, und wer bitteschön developed denn davor?
Der Sound war nur im Stream, der war nicht im Video.
Sorry, ich muss mir das gerade nochmal angucken. Das war ja dermaßen schlecht.
Guck mal, wie das schon reinploppt, Alter.
Zu geil.
Ach du Scheiße.
Boah, okay.
Da lief Windows XP auf dem... Ja, das lief besser.
Okay, es gibt 30 Milliarden Sachen, die nicht funktionieren richtig.
Arch Linux und Manjaro.
Also, ich würde gerne einen von diesen swappen.
Lass mich in den Kommentaren wissen, welches Operationssystem du nächstes Mal auf dem Pine Phone sehen möchtest.
Und ich werde einen von diesen installieren.
Persönlich, lehne ich mich auf Manjaro oder Ubuntu von U-Ports.
Also, ich habe definitiv noch mehr Testen mit dem Pine Phone zu tun.
Und ich bin tatsächlich ziemlich gespannt, weil wir haben...
Nein, ich bin nicht exited dafür, ganz ehrlich. Ich bin absolut null exited.
Kann man darauf Android machen?
Es wäre zu vermuten, ich habe es jetzt nicht gesehen.
Aber generell, glaube ich, ist Android halt immer eine Frage von nicht, ob es läuft.
Laufen tut es überall drauf, also meistens zumindest.
Die Frage ist halt, wie gut.
Also, sprich, gibt es Treiber für die jeweiligen Geräte?
Gibt es Hardware-Acceleration für Videoplayback?
Alles mögliche.
Und das funktioniert halt bei vielen Sachen nicht.
Die haben einen DIP-Switch an ihrem...
Okay.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein Mainboard, so von 1995, aber okay.
Alles klar.
Eigentlich ist das eine coole Idee.
Ich meine, es sieht äußerst behaftungsvoll aus.
Es sieht äußerst behaftungsvoll aus.
Es sieht äußerst behaftungsmäßig und deplatziert aus.
Aber an sich finde ich die Idee cool, dass man gewisse Sachen halt richtig ausschalten kann
und nicht einfach nur ausdrücken kann auf einem Icon.
Ich meine, es ist wie beim iPhone.
Wenn du WLAN ausmachst, WLAN, der nicht richtig aus ist.
Und Bluetooth und solche Geschichten.
Da ist das eigentlich ganz cool.
Das ist definitiv keine Linux-Werbung.
Dafür irgendwie...
Das ist für Entwicklung, nicht für den End-User.
Aber ich bin super gespannt, ob ich eine dieser Hände aufnehmen kann,
damit ich mehr Testen machen kann.
Und wie wir gesehen haben, gibt es bereits viele Operationssysteme für das Pine-Phone.
Also, wenn es eine spezifische Distro gibt, die du sehen möchtest...
Batterie-Powerful, das gucken wir uns jetzt noch an.
Weil die meisten Batterie-Optionen von Raspberry Pi sacken ziemlich.
Die beste, die ich gefunden habe...
Die beste noch.
Halbwegs brauchbar ist so ein billiger China-Adapter für so eine...
Wie heißen die Batterien, die auch in die E-Zigaretten reinkommen?
18, 18, 650 oder so?
Eine Batterie reinkommt und halt einfach mal kurz ein paar Minuten überbrücken kann,
bis der Strom wieder da ist.
Mal gucken, ob das was taugt.
Der macht eigentlich ganz gute Videos.
Ich meine, dass man das Produkt blöd findet, ist ja das eine.
Aber das Video war nicht schlecht.
...für das Raspberry Pi.
Speziell in meinem Fall das Raspberry Pi 4.
Schau dir nochmal das Librem-Linux-Smartphone an.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich mir noch mehr Linux-Smartphones angucken will.
Äh, gucken wir uns das nicht an.
Ich habe einen guten Batteriesaloon ausgesucht.
Verstehe mich nicht falsch, es ist ein tolles...
...Gerächtnis-Modul, und du kannst immer noch eine größere Batterie mit den Verbindungen, die sie hier haben, hinzufügen.
Aber letztlich habe ich tatsächlich gesehen, dass die Batterie völlig...
Warte mal.
...die GPIO-Batterie-Optionen mit der Batterie...
Das ist das Software und ich kann das eigentlich von...
Später gibt es keine Updates mehr.
Und dann...
Wenn ich dir so einen Teil schenke...
Oh ne, ne, ne.
Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Das will ich mir nicht angucken.
Das ist ja Körperverletzung fast schon.
Achso, irgendjemand hat gefragt,
ob ich mir die Apple-Konferenz angucke.
Was ist denn die?
Zehnter...
Das war doch schon.
Dienstag?
Ja.
NTV.
Gibt es die noch?
Stellt Apple am Dienstag das...
iPhone 12 vor...
Tim Cook.
Das neue...
Doch im Corona-Send.
Okay, 15. September.
Uhr.
Was, 19 Uhr?
Wie wäre es mit 19 Uhr?
19 Uhr?
Wenn man es richtig schreiben könnte.
Ah, 19 Uhr.
Ne, das ist...
Ja.
Handy-Raketen.
Also wenn die erste...
Seite Handy-Raketen.de ist.
19 Uhr Dienstag.
Halt schon mal auf.
Äh, das habe ich leider...
Ah, ne, Grafikkarte kaufen.
Ja, 19 Uhr.
Apple.
Und was ist das dann für ein Event?
Das ist...
Das iPhone 12 Event?
Oder Apple...
Okay, da können wir uns wieder...
Eine Sache ist bei Apple-Konferenzen immer cool.
Die haben immer...
Die haben immer cool geschnittene Trailer.
Allerdings sind die absolut Meister
in sich selbst.
Feiern.
Ja, also...
Die können...
Also, sich selbst feiern haben die...
Haben die wirklich drauf.
Vor allem wird da wirklich
absolut jeder geänderte Pixel gefeiert
als die Innovation des Jahrhunderts.
So nach dem Motto,
wir haben eine App,
die jetzt einen gelben Button
statt so einen weißen Button hat.
Und so nach dem Motto,
you have asked for it.
So nach dem Motto,
ihr habt da hunderte Jahre dran gegangen
und jetzt mit gelbem Button.
Das ist so awesome new
und experience und so.
Easy und so krass.
Das ist das Beste, was es gibt.
Das können die bei Apple gut.
Am besten fand ich immer noch die Geschichte,
wo sie vor ein paar Jahren hatten,
wo sie auf der App,
wo sie die Apple Watch gezeigt haben,
wo dann irgendwie...
Ich krieg das nicht mal zusammen,
wo sie eine schwangere Frau hatten
und die hat dann mit der
Apple Watch gemerkt,
dass sie jetzt ins Krankenhaus muss,
weil ihr Kind auf die Welt kommt und so.
Wo ich mir auch gedacht habe,
okay, ich dachte immer,
man merkt das eigentlich auch ohne Apple Watch.
Aber mit Apple Watch merkst du das anscheinend noch besser.
Also die haben ja erzählt,
wir haben da den Herzschlag-Sensor drin
und anhand des Herzschlages von der Mutter
konnte sie dann erkennen,
dass sie jetzt ins Krankenhaus muss
und sowas in der Richtung.
Also das wirkte auf mich schon ein wenig konstruiert
als Begründung dafür,
was jetzt tolles Neues bei der Apple Watch gab.
Oh.
So.
Jetzt schauen wir uns das als nächstes an.
Ach ja, ich sollte ja mal bei AliExpress gucken,
ob ich noch mal USB-Kabel finde.
Das gucken wir mal schnell.
So treibt man nicht.
Ich brauch irgendwas Entspanntes.
Ja, irgendwie sowas.
So, also was ich mir...
AliExpress, nerv nicht rum.
Smartwatch Blitzwolf.
Das, das, das...
Blitzwolf.
Was?
Weltbekannte Hersteller Blitzwolf.
So, ähm, genau.
Ich hab mir so ein 5, äh...
USB-Kabel 50 oder so.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, nach was ich...
Äh, nee, nee, nee, Cable, Cable.
Äh, was hab ich denn damals gesucht?
What?
Äh, Pieces, irgendwie, ähm...
Boah, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, nach was ich gesucht hab.
Ja, Micro-USB, USB-C.
Huge Flashtop hab ich gesucht.
Ja, da kamen irgendwelche, äh, Vibrator-Dinger
als nach USB-Kabel.
Das weiß ich noch, wo ich gedacht hab,
okay, was auch immer die jetzt da...
USB-Kabel machen.
So, und dann hab ich mir eins gekauft,
wo es 50 Stück gab.
Vielleicht hab ich das hier noch in der...
In der History irgendwie?
Nee.
Zumindest hatte ich da ein 50er-Pack gefunden.
Oder was?
Hab ich da noch 100er-Pack gesucht,
dann, dann 50er-Pack gefunden?
Hast du eigentlich eine Alarmanlage,
beziehungsweise kannst du da was empfehlen,
in Kombination mit...
Nee, kann ich dir nix empfehlen.
Nee.
Ja, das ist bei AliExpress teilweise schwierig,
weil man nix findet.
Mini-USB-Huge.
Äh, Mini-USB, keine Ahnung.
Package?
Ich weiß echt nicht mehr,
woher ich gesucht hab,
um den 50er-Pack zu finden.
50 Pieces.
Ja.
Nee.
Set?
Äh.
Tja, gut.
Dann kann ich das jetzt leider nicht zeigen.
Nicht Mini, Mikro.
Mikro.
USB-Stick-Huge hab ich gesucht.
Ja, dann kriegt man...
Warum findet der kein USB-Cable?
Was sucht der da für einen Blödsinn?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich stell das mal hier um.
Das steht noch auf Deutsch.
Das steht auf Deutsch.
Das machen wir weg.
Ähm, wir stellen das auf Sprache...
Englisch.
So, da findet man vielleicht besser.
Naja.
AliExpress.
Nerv...
Alter, geh weg.
Warte.
Ich glaub, AliExpress ist gerade kaputt.
Hä?
Da hab ich doch gerade gesucht.
Warum kann ich das jetzt suchen?
Ich kann das im Bestellverlauf sehen,
aber ich kann das nicht suchen.
aber ich bin ja hier nicht eingeloggt.
Das ist ja mein Streaming-Account.
Hier kommen wir der Sache schon näher.
Irgendwelche Packs.
Oh, 50 Stück.
Sag mal, ist AliExpress kaputt?
Ich glaub, AliExpress ist gerade kaputt.
Die mögen nicht, dass man da sucht.
Ich bin auch im zweiten Bildschirm nicht eingeloggt.
Wenn ich da eingeloggt wäre,
würde ich auch mal nachgucken.
Bin ich aber nicht eingeloggt.
Die gibt's eh nicht.
Die gibt's eh nicht mehr, die ich da bestellt hab.
Zumindest hab ich dort ne 50er-Pack bestellt.
Und die sahen ziemlich ähnlich zu denen hier aus,
die ich bestellt hab.
Moment, Sebaru, du weißt, was ich bestellt hab?
Tatsächlich?
Sebaru, woher weißt du besser als ich,
was für USB-Kabel ich bestellt hab?
Exakt, die hab ich bestellt.
Viel musste man suchen.
Genau.
Viel musste man suchen öfter als...
dabei.
Ja.
Genau.
Genau die hab ich bestellt.
50 Stück.
Micro-USB-Dings.
Äh, ein Meter sogar nur waren's genau.
Doch keine zwei Meter.
Länger vorkommt als ein Meter.
Wahrscheinlich ist es...
Nee, ich hab zwei Meter.
Das ist länger als ein Meter, was ich hab.
Garantiert.
Das geht...
Das geht vom Anschluss-USB-Rechner
Hälfte von meinem Schreibtisch
und da hängt ein Controller dran.
Ist ja auch egal.
Aber sowas...
Das sind ziemlich genau die, die ich bestellt hab.
Ähm...
50 Stück.
Müsst ihr euch...
Aber allerdings...
Allerdings kostenloser Versand
gab's damals noch dabei.
Ähm...
Musst ihr euch mal vorstellen.
Für...
unter einem Euro das Stück
ein USB-Kabel,
Micro-USB,
USB-C.
Also...
China...
China-Kram ist teilweise schon echt
abartig billig, ne?
Wofür braucht man so viele USB-Kabel?
Gar nicht.
Dafür hat man immer USB-Kabel,
wenn man USB-Kabel braucht.
Ich hab mir die gekauft,
weil ich die...
vielleicht mal irgendwann brauche.
Also...
Nee, nicht irgendwann.
Ich werde die nie alle brauchen.
Aber ich suche oft USB-Kabel
und in dem Fall gehe ich ja einfach an die Kiste
und nehme ein USB-Kabel raus.
Dass ich einfach USB...
Dass ich einfach genug USB-Kabel jetzt habe.
Was zum...
Was soll das hier eigentlich sein?
Was ist das?
Nein.
Das ist irgendein Klingelstecker.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Ah, ein Stylus-Stift.
Okay.
Ja.
Muss man nur gucken,
dass man das günstig bekommt.
Und also...
Ähm...
Die...
Leider taugen die Billigen zum Handyladen nicht immer.
Also...
Äh...
Ich hab's jetzt noch gar nicht ausprobiert,
aber Datenübertragung geht okay.
Ich hab da auch die ganzen Controllers immer dran.
Also die funktionieren ganz gut.
Warum fängst du immer die 1 aus der Adresszeile?
Dafür haben wir ein Kommando.
Ausrufezeichen 1.
Das hab ich schon mal erklärt.
Hat keinen tieferen Sinn.
So.
Was schauen wir uns jetzt...
Was schauen wir uns jetzt an?
Battlefield 4 können wir uns mal wieder anschauen.
Lego Tank.
QR-Code.
Flappy Bird.
Game.
Komm, wir gucken uns eine Runde Battlefield 4 an.
Haben wir schon lange nicht mehr geguckt.
Wow.
Das Game ist immer so laut, Alter.
Bzzzt.
Moment.
Was war das?
What the fuck?
War das jetzt einfach Megaglück?
Oder was hat er da gesehen?
Oder ist das hier C4 durch die Wand?
Oder was war das jetzt?
Ich versteh's nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Das Feuer.
Ah, das Feuer.
Doch.
Gegner, please.
Komm.
Ah.
Die checken ja gar nichts wieder.
Das Feuer ist schuld.
Oh je.
Clusterfuck Clips.
Ich mach den nicht so laut, weil die Gameplay-Sachen sind immer laut und er erzählt eh immer das gleiche.
Ich laber da drüber.
Ah, bam.
Das hat Eagle, siehst du wenig in Battlefield allgemein.
Ich hoffe, wenn ich das so seh, ne.
Ich hoffe ja echt, sie kriegen irgendwas halbwegs.
Ich hab gar keine Hoffnung mehr, dass, ähm.
Irgendwie Battlefield 6 für mich da drankommt an 3 oder 4 oder Bad Company 2 oder so.
Aber ich hoffe, dass sie in ein brauchbares Battlefield abliefern, wo ich wenigstens Bock drauf hab, das zu spielen.
Get in the way of its two-shot capability or, of course, the one-shot headshot.
Check out this amazing streak holding this angle on Locker.
Holding this angle.
Ja gut, die laufen eben halt gerade voll rein, ne.
Bam.
Jetzt schreckt.
Next up, it's AK-8.
RX-T coming in with a really nice 11-man backrage on a game of Rush.
Using this AK-971 very well to smash through the enemy lines.
Okay, man sieht viel.
Battlefield, Battle Royale.
Die haben es so verkackt mit Firestorm, ne.
Firestorm hatte auch dieses Plattenfeature von, äh.
Warzone und.
Ich glaube.
Wie to play.
Hätte Firestorm durchaus ne gewisse Playerbase haben können.
Aber so nicht.
Ich meine, spielt hier auch keiner mehr.
Guck dir mal.
Warte mal.
Wir gucken jetzt mal.
Twitch.
Oh, nicht.
Nein, nein.
Ich mach mir jetzt nicht selbst auf.
Ich geh fort.
Ähm.
Firestorm.
Ne.
Jetzt ist es Royal Firestorm.
Ja.
Ist es nicht so?
Firestorm Royale oder so.
Ja.
Äh.
Ähm.
Ja.
Last year.
Ähm.
Ja.
Da spielt.
Da spielt keiner.
Ich mein.
Battlefield 5.
Guckt euch das mal an.
185 Viewer.
Das Game ist so.
Am Arsch.
Der Wahnsinn.
Muss aber stehen geblieben.
Hier.
Ne.
Da.
OP G18.
Ja.
A clip in a similar position is Megatron is back.
But this time he's gonna be using the big M249 to smash through.
Bis in a similar position is Megatron is back.
Bis die Helden machen den Clip vielleicht.
Siehst ja nix.
A point that nearly reaches 2000 in total.
Auuu.
Die Gegner.
An 11 man streak from Dexter.
This one's really interesting as he's within this little section.
Ah genau.
Das ist hier auf Locker.
Da wo das Klo in der Zelle steht.
Da kann.
Kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Hier an die.
Den Abschnitt von der Map.
Das ist hier auf Locker.
Da wo das Klo in der Zelle steht.
Da kann.
Kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
A.E.K. hat keine Ahnung, dass A.E.K. die perfekte Waffe für das ist und einen großen Spraydown
zu den Enemien draußen hat.
Treffe nix.
Aber G18, also eins muss man echt sagen, die G18 war in dem Game,
echt übertrieben.
Das ist quasi eine zweite Primary-Waffe,
die man dabei hat. So eine zweite SMG.
Ja, A.E.K. und G18, das ist
das ist wirklich
eine gute Kombi hier.
Damit kannst du nicht allzu viel verkehrt
machen. Das ist ungefähr so, wie wenn du in Battlefield 3
M16 only spielst.
Wobei es halt in Battlefield 4
viel mehr Auswahl gibt. Es ist übrigens gar keine A.E.K.
Hört mir grad mal so auf.
Das war der Typ vorher.
Aber die Gegner
haben es auch nicht so mit rumgucken, oder?
Die laufen einfach blind um die Ecke.
So wie er jetzt.
War das jetzt?
Bumm!
Oh, nice!
Das ist ein cooler Clip.
Ja gut, die G18 muss ja anscheinend schon sein.
Die Gegner sind völlig lost.
Ja, das stimmt. Allerdings ist es
in Battlefield 3, 4, Bad Company 2
auch so. Gerade, wenn du ein Team hast,
was halt anteilmäßig deutlich
überlegen ist an Spielern,
du zerstörst die halt teilweise komplett.
Da kannst du auch wirklich ein paar ganz gute Gegner haben.
Eins, zwei. Die können da auch nicht
großartig gegenhalten.
Die können vielleicht ein paar Leute killen.
Von dir aber.
Also, wenn die Teams da
unausgeglichen sind, da sieht jeder
übelst lost aus im Battlefield.
Also, in dem Teil zumindest.
Ich meine, gut, dass die jetzt nicht gucken
und einfach nur gerade auslaufen, ist natürlich low.
Absolut low brain.
Auf der anderen Seite merke ich, das kenne ich
selbst noch, manchmal verlierst du auch einfach,
hast auch einfach keinen Bock mehr und versuchst irgendwie
noch durchzukommen, dass die Runde vielleicht doch noch halbwegs
was wird.
Oh, man merkt sofort,
dass es Konsole ist.
Auflösung und geruckelt.
Konsole Grafix.
Oh, wenn sie schön als Sniper Clip ist.
Und noch low brainigere Gegner.
Allerdings nehmen sich da die Plattformen wirklich nicht viel.
Es gibt überall absolute.
BB-Gas.
First is going to be using the ace 23 going on an eleven kill streak in total,
starting out with a couple of kills.
They're just playing in this stairwell.
Unfortunately, it takes a flash fully in the face.
Just wait your face.
Wait for that to go.
Thankfully, no one pushes and then he slowly pushes towards
his enemy players.
His team is losing.
They need to make up.
Rage ist in Battlefield 4 wirklich nicht so gut gewesen.
Deswegen mag ich auch Battlefield 3 immer noch am liebsten.
B C 1 gab's ja nicht auf dem PC.
Oh, Moment, den Clip kennen wir.
Oder haben wir einfach viele so ähnliche Clips schon gesehen?
Wahrscheinlich.
Oh.
Alter, wie sie sich wegsprayen lassen.
The second clip you sent in, you can see him spawning here with an 870 MCS.
Another eleven kill streak.
We've had quite a few today that are eleven kills in total.
Starting out with a nice kill with that M26 mass, pushing through.
Könnt ihr euch, vielleicht die Leute, die Battlefield 3 gespielt haben,
Könnt ihr euch noch an den Bug von dieser Underbarrel Shotgun erinnern?
Wo du quasi über die ganze Map Leute one-shotten konntest,
obwohl es die normale Shotgun war, ohne Slugs und alles.
Wo du einfach nur diese, mit diesen Darts, diese Dart Shotgun,
die du unter's Gewehr machen konntest,
und wo du einfach komplett über die gesamte Map die Leute snipen konntest.
M26 war ein Start, genau.
Das war so extrem OP.
Aber hat Bock gemacht.
Zum Glück haben sie schnell gepatcht.
Venise Unleashed, lul, das wird's nie geben.
Grip.
Venom Helix kommt mit einem 17-Kill-Streak in unter einer Minute,
direkt am Hintergrund der Map hier,
Echo objective, the only one that is left to cap.
You've seen this sort of clip before.
The enemies are desperately trying to push out,
but whenever you get a flank, they're all gonna be facing one way.
And just as he deals with a couple of guys behind him who are spawning in,
Das Rumgehüppe hat halt in Battlefield 3 und 4 öfters mal schön rumgebuckt.
Dass die Sprunganimation gemacht hat und du bist da nicht gesprungen.
Gerade in Battlefield 3 war das richtig eklig.
In Battlefield 5 haben sie es ja so gelöst,
du darfst einfach nicht mal an vielen Stellen springen.
Das ist natürlich die Low-Brain-Lösung.
Das ist nicht x-te Solution,
das ist x-te Kacklösung für Battlefield-Animationen.
Oh, das war auch mega schlecht, ey.
Zumindest ist es total bescheuert,
wenn man feststellt, sein Animationssystem funktioniert nicht.
Einfach zu sagen, ja gut,
da dürft ihr halt über manche Sachen nicht mal drüber springen,
dass das Animationssystem funktioniert.
Was haben sie in Battlefield 5 gemacht?
Und Battlefield 1 auch schon.
Battlefield 3 und 4 bist du halt dafür fünfmal an einer Wand drüber gesprungen
und nie drüber gekommen.
Manchmal.
Moin, Cybergear.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Willst du Cyberpunk zocken?
Ich probier's wahrscheinlich mal aus.
Ja, aber ich muss halt sagen,
auch wenn das die Witcher-Leute sind,
so wirklich mein Setting ist es nicht.
Es ist einfach unglaublich,
dass man mit 15 Runden,
bevor man sich zurückladen muss,
es ist unglaublich,
gegen eine Menge Gegner.
Schau dir das an, für eine große Rückgrätschung.
Rückgrätschung?
So, so.
Aber richtig,
eine große Rückgrätschung gibt's hier.
Ascend Savant kommt mit einem 7-Mann-M98-B-Clip mit,
der sich auf ein Spiel von Rush anschaut,
um...
Was, wie trifft er da was?
Ach ja, nochmal sieht er was.
Und er kann sich aufhören,
einen wirklich tollen Feed zu machen.
Sario beendet heute's Episode
mit einem anderen Clip.
Dieser wird wieder einmal
mit dem Skar-Rage verwendet,
nur um so lange wie möglich zu überleben,
in seiner sehr schwierigen Position.
Äh...
Ich glaube, das nächste Battlefield wird modern,
mehr weiß man nicht.
Moderner.
Ich glaube auch, dass sie sich
an Crossplay probieren werden.
Gerade Warzone hat aber gezeigt mit Crossplay,
dass es eigentlich doch nicht richtig funktioniert.
Warzone ist, je nachdem,
in welcher Situation du bist,
sind andere Plattformen unfair.
Ja, wenn's um, äh...
Tracking-Range über Range geht,
wo Auto-Aim nicht mehr greift,
ist Maustastatur einfach OP,
gegen Controller.
Geht es um Nahkampf-Range,
wo du, äh...
Easy-Controller-Ranzoom-Auto-Aim machen kannst,
ist Controller OP.
Also, der weiß halt,
letzter Schluss ist es irgendwie nicht.
Vielleicht kriegen sie es besser hin.
Au, das war ein cooler Clip.
Das sind auch nicht so...
Das sind auch nicht so ultra...
Also, Gott, die reagieren halt langsam.
Aber die meisten Gegner erkennen zumindest,
dass er da ist.
Also, die G18.
Ich hab, ach mein Gott,
der ist ein kleiner Schwerkopf.
Wir gucken mal, wie viele Konkurrenten
das da haben und wir gucken mal,
wie viele Fälle die da haben,
da sind, ähm...
Da sind noch alle wieder da.
Da sind noch die, ähm...
Da sind noch alles noch nicht da,
aber wenn ihr das freut,
dann lasst einen Daumen hoch.
Da mit dem Video
und dann die Karte unten,
da unten, in der Rung.
Äh, was?
Mit was?
Denn die RAM-Clearance.
Weiß ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Abstand RAM-Lüfter.
Ja, sehr, sehr knapp.
Sehr, sehr knapp.
Massive knapp.
Passt aber.
Passt.
Ist aber wirklich enorm knapp.
Du darfst auf keinen Fall RAM nehmen, der den Lüfter, der obendrauf noch Kühlrippen oder sowas hat.
Das passt, aber es ist extrem knapp.
Ansonsten machst du einfach den Kühler ab.
Kannst einfach abziehen an der Seite.
Nee, aber es passt.
Extrem knapp.
Wie sieht das aus mit neuer Hardware bei dir?
Ja, es gibt ja noch keine neuen AMD-CPUs.
Ich bin noch unschlüssig, ob ich am 29. eine neue Grafikkarte vorbestelle.
Oder war es 24.?
Es kann auch 24. anstatt 29. gewesen sein.
Aktuell habe ich eine 1080 Ti.
Seit dreieinhalb Jahren oder so schon.
Man muss sich mal vorstellen, ich habe so oft schon gesagt,
einen Rechner vor drei Jahren und eine Grafikkarte von vor dreieinhalb Jahren,
die immer noch zu den besten Systemen gehört.
Das ist doch der Witz.
Das ist total lächerlich.
Also, ich bin halt noch die Zeiten gewöhnt, wo du einen Rechner nach zwei Jahren wegschmeißen konntest,
weil es Müll war.
Also ich glaube, ich werde mir...
Also vorausgesetzt AMD kommt demnächst mal mit neuen CPUs an den Start,
die sich lohnen zu kaufen.
Dann baue ich mir dieses Jahr noch ein Ryzen-System mit 3.900,
sofern es irgendwie ansatzweise lieferbar ist.
Ansonsten warte ich da bis nächstes Jahr.
Ich habe mir da wirklich keine Eile dahinter.
Es ist jetzt ja egal.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt mein Rechner von Top 5% der Systeme auf einmal mega schlecht wird.
Ja, genau.
Das habe ich auch mitgekriegt, dass demnächst AMD neue Sachen vorstellt.
Allerdings, AMD hat ja allgemein schon Lieferschwierigkeiten.
Also AMD hat jetzt Lieferschwierigkeiten.
Aktuell schon.
Also jetzt gerade.
Naja gut, GPU ist AMD, aber...
Lieferprojekte, genau.
Die haben jetzt schon teilweise Probleme, die Sachen zu liefern.
Und die haben es letztes Jahr ja auch gemacht, dass ein 3950X,
das ja ein bisschen später kam, und dann nicht lieferbar war.
Also ich habe echt meine Zweifel, ob ich dieses Jahr noch einen ordentlichen neuen Ryzen
in der Hand halte.
Ich warte, ne, also dann, also sobald, also sollte es so sein, dass AMD eine neue CPU-Generation
rausbringt, die nennenswert schneller ist als mein 8700K, sowohl halt als auch in Spiele-Performance,
was aktuell halt eben absolut nicht der Fall ist, als auch Multicore, weil Multicore ist
halt einfach dadurch, dass ich nur 6 Kerne habe.
Nur 6 Kerne habe.
Versus irgendwie einen aktuellen Ryzen mit sonst was, 12, 16 oder 16 Kern.
Das ist natürlich ein Riesenunterschied, aber so viel Multicore brauche ich gar nicht.
Ich bin mit 6 Kern eigentlich ganz zufrieden, ja.
Es gibt, also Spiele brauchen eh nicht mehr.
Bei Spielen ist ja beim Weniger am meisten schon Schluss.
Und selbst wenn ich Spiele und VMs laufen habe und alles mögliche, 6 Kerne reichen auch.
Also, ähm...
Das heißt, das ist so sekundär.
Also mehr Kerne sind cool, allerdings wichtig ist die Kombination.
Also ich will, dass das Ding schon schneller ist als mein 8700K und auch schneller als
der 8700K übertaktet und mehr Kerne hat.
Und erst wenn nennenswert, nennenswert schneller ist und nennenswert mehr Kerne hat und erst
wenn beides wirklich auch mal so ab, sagen wir mal 15, 20% mehr Leistung ankommt, dann
lohnt sich das für mich überhaupt was Neues zu kaufen.
Ansonsten, ich muss ja nicht zwangsläufig Geld ausgeben.
Ich weiß...
Mir juckt's extrem in den Finger, neue Hardware zu kaufen.
Aber wozu?
Wozu sollte ich jetzt 4000 Euro oder Geschiss für einen neuen Rechner ausgeben mit High-End-CPU
und High-End-GPU, wenn ich einen aktuellen Rechner habe, der unterm Strich dann, keine Ahnung,
nur 10% langsamer ist in den meisten Anwendungen.
Ist auch vollkommen bescheuert.
Und obwohl er schon 3 Jahre alt ist.
Striker 890 schreibt, naja, Konsolen haben auch mehr Kerne, also werden die Spiele auch
immer mehr Richtung mehr Kerne optimiert.
Das lese ich.
Das lese ich oft, glaube ich aber nicht.
Denn, also ich gebe dir, ich gehe da insoweit mit, wenn man sagt, dass die sich natürlich
an der aktuellen Konsolen, am aktuellen Konsolenstand orientieren, so ein bisschen auch an den
Möglichkeiten, die Konsolen haben, auch sei es jetzt Unity, Unreal oder sonst was, dass
die auch quasi Fokus drauf legen, dass man das besonders gut unterstützt.
Aber es ist ja nicht so, dass wenn sie, wenn es easy wäre, da irgendwelche Optimierungen
zu machen.
Wenn man das auf dem PC nicht schon gemacht hätte.
Dazu kommt nämlich, und das ist eigentlich der Hauptpunkt, warum ich nicht glaube, dass
das in diesem Ausmaß passieren wird, man kann die Sachen auch nur bis zu einem gewissen
Grad optimieren.
Also es gibt halt einfach Sachen, die kannst du nicht gut parallelisieren und schon gar
nicht auf 10 Kerne oder 8 Kerne sinnvoll parallelisieren.
Die ersten paar Kerne sind einfach.
Also sagen wir mal, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du Rendering, was weiß ich, du machst,
du machst irgendwie Soundberechnung, KI-Berechnung, sonstige Geschenke.
Also du kannst, du hast am Anfang noch relativ viele unabhängigen, recht unabhängige Sachen
voneinander, die nicht auf den Ergebnissen von anderen Berechnungen aufbauen.
Die kannst du relativ einfach parallelisieren.
Zwei, drei Kerne, vier Kerne, würde ich sagen, kriegst du da noch ganz gut mit, ohne größere
Verrenkungen in deinem Hirn zu machen, kriegst du damit noch ganz gut gefüttert.
Ja?
Zwar auch nicht alle auf 100 Prozent, aber du kriegst, du kriegst da zumindest noch gut
Performance raus.
Umso mehr das wird, umso schwieriger wird der Kram zu parallelisieren.
Es liegt nicht, es geht nicht nur einfach darum, dass die neuen Konsolen mehr Kerne
haben.
Du musst auch die Sachen grundsätzlich so aufbauen, dass sie sich gut parallelisieren
können.
Und es gibt einfach Sachen, die kannst du unglaublich schlecht parallelisieren.
Sys0 abonniert Stufe 1, drei Monate, Dankeschön, Exzellenz.
Subscription.
Manche sagen, kannst du einfach nicht gescheit parallelisieren.
Und gerade wenn es Berechnungen sind, die eben Ergebnisse vorangegangener Berechnungen
brauchen, da wird es ultra kompliziert.
Deswegen glaube ich nicht, dass wir Spiele sehen werden, die sinnvoll, keine Ahnung,
zwölf Kerne oder zehn Kerne richtig gut ausnutzen.
Es mag Spiele geben, wo das richtig gut geht.
Sagen wir jetzt mal irgendwelche Echtzeitstrategiespiele mit vielen Einheiten.
Wo viele unterschiedlichen Sachen unterschiedlich unabhängig voneinander passieren oder sowas.
Da kann ich mir das noch halbwegs vorstellen.
Aber bei den meisten sonst bei den normalen Mainstream-Spielen, ich glaube, ist das unglaublich
schwierig, zwölf Kerne sinnvoll auszulasten.
SLI und Crossfire braucht ja auch kein Mensch.
Macht eben, hat schon immer mehr Probleme gemacht, als es gebracht hat.
Ja.
Also ich kenne das halt aus Softwareentwicklungssicht.
Sachen zu parallelisieren ist nicht einfach.
Und man macht viele Sachen absichtlich sequenziell, weil du dadurch viele Probleme einfach nicht hast.
Es sind ja auch viele Sachen, die man umgedreht gesagt, viele Sachen, die man parallelisieren kann, sind parallel gar nicht unbedingt schneller.
Nehmen wir mal einfach, du hast eine Liste aus Zahlen, du willst sie sortieren.
Das kann man teilweise parallelisieren.
Allerdings ist es oftmals sequenziell schneller, weil das kommt immer auf die Größe der Liste an, ja.
Aber du hast eine Liste mit ein paar Millionen, mit ein paar Millionen Einträgen drin, die willst du sortieren.
Das ist sequenziell schneller, als du machst vier Threads auf, synchronisierst die Joints dir am Ende wieder, machst nochmal einen letzten Sortiervorgang oben drüber.
Hast verschiedene Kontext, wo das Ganze läuft.
CPU-Cache passt nicht mehr zueinander.
Das ist sequenziell schneller.
Obwohl es theoretisch relativ gut sich parallelisieren lässt und auch theoretisch ziemlich gut skaliert über mehrere Kerne, aber es ist, wenn du es dann ausprobierst und auch mal nachmachst, ist es sequenziell tatsächlich immer noch schneller.
Allein schon, wenn du eine Liste hast am Stück, weil du Sachen im Voraus schon in deinen CPU-Cache laden kannst, was du mit unterschiedlichen Threads nicht so einfach machen kannst.
Also viele Sachen, die sehen erstmal gut aus zu parallelisieren, lohnt sich aber gar nicht.
Wenn du dann irgendwann mal vielleicht, wenn die Liste dann auf einmal fünf Millionenfach größer ist, also generell verschiedene Threads oder Multithreads machen, lohnt sich erst ab einer gewissen Länge der Aufgaben.
Also selbst wenn du die Bilderbuch-Anwendungen hast, die sich perfekt parallelisieren lässt, wenn das nur ganz kleine Häppchen sind, dann ist die Kosten dafür, das zu parallelisieren, höher, als es einfach sequenziell zu machen.
Also eine Sache, die halt wirklich richtig...
Und das zeigt, wie man richtig gut mehrere Kerne auslasten kann, ist halt Video-Encoding.
Video-Encoding ist wunderbar zu parallelisieren.
Die eine Aufgabe hängt überhaupt nicht mit der anderen zusammen.
Video-Encoding ist eine super Geschichte.
Du kannst dein Video in komplett unterschiedliche Brocken zerhacken und encoden auf nahezu beliebig vielen Kernen, wie du lustig bist.
Du musst dann zwar am Ende ein bisschen gucken, dass das alles...
Prinzipiell geht das.
Und auch Grafikberechnungssachen, es heißt jetzt irgendwelche Berechnungen, wo kommt welcher Pixel hin, welche Farbe hat welcher Pixel, also das, was so Grafikkarten machen, läuft meist auch wunderbar parallel.
Es gibt Sachen, die gehen gut parallel, aber halt viele Sachen, die sind ziemlich schwierig parallel zu machen.
Oder manche Sachen lohnen sich gar nicht.
Und auch Grafikkarte ist ein gutes Beispiel.
Viele Sachen lohnen sich nicht, auf der Grafikkarte zu machen.
Das lohnt sich.
Und dort auch erst ab einer gewissen Komplexität und einer gewissen Länge, wie das Ganze dauert.
Weil, du darfst nicht vergessen, du musst die Daten erstmal zur Grafikkarte pushen und die Grafikkarte dann berechnen lassen.
Und das Uploaden zur Grafikkarte von deinem Zeug kann durchaus schon unsinnigerweise viel länger dauern, als einfach, okay, CPU, ratter mal drüber.
Das ist wirklich sehr individuell abhängig von dem, was man machen will.
Und Multithreading-Parallelisierung ist...
...echt kein einfaches Feld.
Und umso komplizierter das wird, wird es nicht nur komplizierter, die Sache an sich gut zu parallelisieren, sondern du musst auch aufpassen, dass du dir keine Bugs einfängst, sodass das eine früher fertig ist, als das andere und da schon Sachen schreibt und das andere wartet, dass das da ist und dann kriegst du irgendwelche Deadlocks, weil das eine wartet auf A, aber A wartet auch auf B und B wartet indirekt über C auf A.
Das ist nicht einfach, als ordentlich zu machen.
So, deswegen glaube ich, dass wir das, dass die Konsolen doch schon ein bisschen Einfluss drauf haben werden, wie ich am Anfang gesagt habe.
Sollte da Unity und Unreal jetzt quasi die, hat wir natürlich besonders gut benutzen wollen, vielleicht sehen wir da ein bisschen Verbesserungen, die auch sich auf PC durchschlagen, aber im Großen und Ganzen sehe ich nicht, sehe ich nicht, dass irgendwie PC-Spiele mal 10 oder 12 Kerne gescheit benutzen.
Ja.
Genau.
So.
So viel dazu.
Äh, Leute, ich habe übelst Hunger.
Also, ähm, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie wir es machen.
Also, wenn ich heute nicht auf die Arbeit muss, wovon ich mal ausgehe, ehrlich gesagt, weil es hat sich hier noch keiner gerührt und ich sehe hier auch keine Messages oder sowas.
Gucken, ob E-Mails wieder gehen mittlerweile.
Ähm, heute ist Sonntag, ja.
Ja, wie gesagt, bei uns sind ein paar Sachen kaputt.
Ich war auch von, äh, Freitagmorgen bis Samstag, also, kürzer Unterbrechung, Samstag, 15 Uhr da am Start.
Deswegen habe ich ja auch die letzten Tage überhaupt nichts gestreamt.
Vielleicht, also, mal gucken, wie es morgen ist.
Morgen habe ich ja eigentlich frei.
Mal gucken, wie es da ist.
Ähm, da basteln wir mal einen Mini-Webserver auf dem ESP32 zusammen.
Ich habe ja schon angefangen und ein bisschen geguckt, wie das funktioniert.
Weil, äh, wohlgemerkt.
Einen TLS, also SSL-fähigen, ähm, Webserver.
Wir verwenden eine Library, die mit dabei ist.
Und das können wir im Stream, äh, bisschen, bisschen rumbasteln.
Äh, Max, könntest du mal Flutter-Web probieren im Stream?
Wäre toll.
Könnten wir mal auf, könnten wir mal aufschreiben.
Hatten wir das nicht sogar schon mal aufgeschrieben?
Irgendwas?
Flutter?
Flutter, hier.
Ist doch, steht doch.
Haben wir doch, hatten wir schon mal drin.
Flutter-Web-Website, warum auch immer.
Das heißt eigentlich nur Flutter-Web.
Ja, ich schreibe mir das nochmal auf.
Der Desktop.
Ja, da ist der Chat dran schuld.
Da kann ich ja nichts für.
Ja, Leute, ich glaube, ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Ich bin immer noch ein bisschen müde.
Dadurch, weil ich ja nachts auf der Arbeit rumgesprungen bin.
Und, wie gesagt, vielleicht gehen wir nachher oder morgen, je nachdem, wie es mit der Arbeit ausschaut,
machen wir weiter und basteln noch ein bisschen Web-Server zusammen.
Und wir haben ja noch zig andere.
Wir können, wir können noch tausend Sachen machen.
Muss da plus Zeit für haben.
Alles klar.
Leute, wir sehen uns.
Ich gehe was futtern.
Bis zum nächsten Stream.
Macht's gut.
See you.